This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Well,
no,
Christina
[inaudible] [inaudible]
very exciting times. I have a
cold, which is not exciting,
but nevertheless,
we're here doing another episode of
your mom's clam and let's see Jean.
Yeah, I've got a couple
things coming up this weekend.
I'll be in Fresno and Bakersfield.
Bakersfield has some single seats
left so you'd have to sit alone,
but you could get in. There's probably
30 tickets left. Fresno has a few more.
That's this weekend, Friday
and Saturday. Then a,
in a couple of weeks I go to Fort Myers,
Florida on November 1st sub tickets there.
Jacksonville has some single seats left.
That's on the second.
Um, Orlando was all sold out and
there's a few tickets left. And Augusta,
that's that first weekend in
November. That's right. Um,
single seats left on the Wednesday
in Montclair. That's the 14th mom,
Claire at the Walmart Theater.
Then I go to fill her up Delfia and the
only show with some tickets is the late
show. Friday. I'm doing four shows
at the Merriam theater in Philly.
Delphia and I will be a
Friday and Saturday there.
The late show,
the 16th of November has tickets.
I'm very excited to announce that I
added some stuff for the new tour,
the 2019 take it down tour
and here's what I got.
That was just just added.
We just added a third show
in San Diego on January 12th.
We just added a third show in Oklahoma
City on January 22nd a third show in
Dallas,
Texas on January 27 at the majestic,
a second show in Pittsburgh
on Valentine's Day.
Uh, that's a second show in Pittsburgh
and a second show in Portland,
Maine on March 26.
Uh,
those are all at Thompson.
gretta.com/tour Jean Jean.
Well first of all,
October 30th mark your calendars,
the degenerates premiers on net friend.
So check that out.
And then I'm 2019 days.
Yes,
yes.
I'm going to be announcing
a 2019 tour on October 30th.
So check back for those dates
and cities on Christina p online.
Now in the meantime,
before I hit the road,
I'm running my hour at flip pairs comedy
club this Sunday in Sperm Bank in the u
who room. It's a tiny room. I like to
do small shows before I do big ones.
Kinda how you guys see us make the
sausage, the comedy sausage so to speak.
So get your ticks. There's like a
few ticks. A few left. Yeah, man.
November 10th, west
Salaam, Salaam Springs,
Oklahoma at the Cherokee casino.
Uh,
November 24th I've added a late show
in San Diego at the House of Blues,
the 10:00 PM show,
fill her up.
Delphia we added a late show December
7th and then a December 8th do dark
titties,
added a late show,
the Gramercy theater and those tickets
are almost completely gone again.
Christina P on line.
Thank you. I love you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah man. Yeah man. Yeah
man. I mean I'm, yeah, I'm yeah.
Oh, I like it. I like it. Okay.
Okay. Alright. Okay. Alright. Alright.
Uh, no matter and I, Tom,
he said your mother and I are
looking forward to this next chapter.
Um, your mother. And so let's
get into this gene, your mother.
Very exciting stuff. Pick show.
Ready. Oh yeah. Here we go. I'm ready,
mother. Here we go. Let's
go home. Oh, Yep. Oh,
that guy looks totally normal though.
Uh, pierce rattlesnakes.
Yeah. And drink while
a spit rare of snakes,
peers, Dan. The line.
I sleep out under a new
tree when the moon is full.
Okay.
Yep.
Well,
we'll go to your mom's house.
Who wrote this in my book says
Focus. Christina, you wrote this.
You're writing, what's the last word?
I can't read that as you're writing kiss.
Let me see.
Did you write me that rescue something
and then that's your writing, isn't it?
Yeah, that is. We like to a little
focus, Christina. Focus. Focus. Yeah.
You know what?
I like a little known Mott.
We'll let you in on a very intimate
mommy's secret is that Tom and I,
since we first started seeing each other,
we always have these comedy notebooks.
You always see me scribbling.
Yeah.
And we would go into the deep
pages and write each other,
messed up masters or draw
pictures of dicks and balls. Um,
our favorite thing to do on airplanes,
those magazines,
memories to draw dicks like on every
page of the, the skymall catalog.
Yeah. And then put it back. It's great.
You know, that's a gift to somebody
who's sitting there
came all magazine.
Defacement is probably one of my
favorite things we've done in the area.
I forgot. We, we should do that again.
That's another thing you
can do to spice things up.
Um, how are you doing?
How you feeling right now?
Oh, it's hired. We had a crazy
weekend. Our both our kids are sick.
Everybody's getting sick. You're getting
sick. The baby had a fever yesterday,
so I had to run them to the doctor.
And you know what they always
say when you bring your kid in.
Yeah. It's a virus. We find the
worst part of that fleet, honestly,
getting sick during this God
damn challenge. Oh right.
And you know,
your body just wants to
rest and I'm falling behind.
So the current standings right now,
right.
And sober fart Tobar Sober October
and the bane of my existence,
then there's not that much time left.
There's about a week left. Yeah. And it,
it had been pretty close for a while
and then Joe went nuts a few days.
You knew it was coming.
He's pulled far in a way ahead of us.
Um,
so really it's a competition now between
Bert Ari and I wish we kind of always
knew it would be. Yeah,
it's been neck and neck,
but like yesterday I just
couldn't do anything excessive.
You know, my body was just
like, you need to round. Yeah.
But then you're like, fuck,
like you have to get something even
on the low. The whole thing is,
I've always gotten points every day
because if you let a day go by, it's just,
you're,
you're in too deep of a hole.
So even if you walk around and get some
points, you know, going on a long walk,
can you wear this telemetry
strap just all day? Good.
Can we put it on one of the dogs
and the dog ran in the backyard?
I don't think it will register the dog,
but like so,
but it's just one of those
things where like, dude,
our kid runs all day and put it on him.
I wish it burns calories so it'd
be like you really very active.
Oh, crazy. Yeah, but like I just
fucking, I did great the day before.
I've been,
I've been doing it all month,
but then feeling like this doesn't
make you want to run when you're sick.
You don't want to live.
You don't want to do shit science,
so it sucks your will to live. I know
y'all are. Hopefully it'll be better soon.
He's got to take drugs. I don't know
what drugs to take. Dayquil all right.
Maybe I'll take some dayquil. Get
yourself jacked. You'll jack me up,
Jack you off. Okay. Speaking
of that opening clip,
doesn't that feel like your first six
years in standup? Like every open mic? Oh,
I thought meant like,
doesn't this feel
like retro? Your mind does.
That's what it feels like for me.
Like I got such a big smile
when I saw this. I was like,
this is what this show's all about.
I did an interview with Larry King,
that's right, yesterday, yesterday, and
it'll be out in a few weeks, a week.
The movie comes out and he was like,
who would you love to have on your
mom's house? And I was like, um,
I don't know man. Because I was like, I
dunno. I started talking about it. I go,
we like trash TV like Bravo.
And he was like, what?
But I really wanted to say I
should have said like a CAS ripper.
That's exactly why I was thinking.
Yeah I didn't,
he did say he was like, he was like, so
what do you like on your show? I was like,
you know, we like to play like
viral interact clips of like,
like a guy who's like really high on meth
and he just wants to invite strangers
who have sex with him.
And he was like reflects.
I think that's the challenge of writing
this CBS pilot that we're doing right
now.
Like
how's the pilot? And I'm like, you know
what? We're really trying to keep it real.
Your mom's house is, I mean within
the confines of a network show,
the spirit being the same.
We can't have a guy being like I came
in for strokes so much thick cap com
couldn't believe up big his dick was,
but I was going to say that guy cause I
went to do a show at Bar Lubitsch and I
was watching like younger male comics
and the first six years it's just
masturbation. Like all they talk about
is jerky and headaches, which is fine.
I'm not just saying it's just, it
reminded me of like, Oh yeah, this is,
oh this guy's got some other materials.
If you want to see some of his stuff here,
let's go and do it again.
Piss rattlesnake. Yeah, this is
Matt Kras. Remember this guy?
I spit rattlesnakes.
This is Dan and this is an open mind.
I sleep out under a no,
it is kind of like a bowling
alley. Canoga bowl. Sunday night,
fuck under covered darkness.
Black women only cause
the Sun Keynes file.
They like animals, beasts, raccoons,
foxes in sheets. God,
I love this shit. Wow.
Dangers. You know, maybe I do like
spoken word is pretty good stuff.
If it were like this,
yeah I'd watch this all day.
Why are we so attracted to this?
Lights me up inside.
This guy is a hero.
I like poopy.
You say poopy and my face lights up and
crazy people like I had. I love Gigi.
Allen is fucking guy.
Steve Lives is smooth
and pink times sweet.
I loved tastes that Pussy Pussy.
Me Nick.
Oh Pussy is Reimann quite a
bit. It's good. It's not bad.
Drink the pussy meat or eat to put and
then drink the nectar that it secretes.
We need, this is off the top of
the dome. Pretty good. Pretty good.
Somebody needs to lay a beat under
this. Uh Oh. I'm sure they will.
I'm sure they will.
I like how we take black dandelion wine.
Is that right?
All right. Sassafras
water, orange mass spine.
The color of a mud puddle,
which shoots at the water line.
Hey now lack to lick the pedals of
iron roofs and then class and Brian.
Hm.
I mean this stream of
consciousness is pretty aggressive.
It's actually really good.
It sounds like he wants to get mudded.
It sounds like he may be under
the influence of something. No,
but that's the whole thing is this drugs
or mental illness is an interesting
segment. Yeah. We need a awesome
intro. Music for a mental illness or,
or drugs. Drugs are metal.
Yeah. I'm going to go, uh,
the intensity of the eyes,
the cadence.
I'm going to go mental illness.
Uh, maybe schizophrenia,
the stream of consciousness here.
Uh,
cause math guy tried out that guy's
math, right? We learned that. Yeah. Uh,
that's more aggressive and
a lot of shoulder asks. He,
this guy could be mushrooms, acid,
this, you know, maybe could be,
I'm feeling his intense eye contact.
That's mental illness to me
right now. Weird. Crazy. Yeah.
The boat for my lover.
Guilt or in a minute with golden silver.
Starla yeah.
On an Egf.
Shinra I want fashioned
a boat for my lover.
I just also feel like, you know,
it's not high production. Yeah.
But the fact that he knows to have a
microphone and a light and a camera on,
Whoa, wait a minute.
It's pretty good. I mean,
this is not your typical, your
mom's house. Wait a minute.
It's kind of frame semi correctly. I
like the lighting. The lighting is,
it's deliberate. It's not right, but it's,
it's a choice. And I,
but the biggest thing,
the biggest credit we have
to give them is audio. Wow.
You're right.
And I like his Iggy pop thing.
He's kind of shirtless with the
long weird hair. Uh, you're right.
This is kind of a revelation that guy.
See now I'm going on for drugs because
mental illness wouldn't have the
wherewithal, right. It could be drugs.
Yeah. Drugs. You have the focus.
Let us know sir. Which is, which is it
Mary?
She who wants to leave forever with
me under the leaves twinkling in dark
forest.
[inaudible] blind in gripping tightly
in the hand each and Desti rough chunk a
time.
I tell Ya. Asheville, North Carolina,
they've got a lot of talented people. So
yeah, that guy's pretty exact guy
from North Carolina. I have no idea.
But that's what I saw. Can he open
for you? Yeah, he could open for me.
What have you brought to this guy?
That's my new contest.
How insane can I make my
openers? B, that would be so fun.
This guy's are opening your audience.
So if they knew what was going on,
it would be really fun. You know,
if they knew we were like,
it's going to be crazy at my shows,
I'm going to pay out an
absolute best person.
We could do like a gong show of crazy
people in the eye. But if you just,
if you just surprise them, whether it'd be
a lot of disappointment, you know? Yeah.
They got to be in on it.
You gotta be well cause this
truly for more than 30 seconds,
you can't really sit through
this. It's pretty painful. Yeah.
This is like open mic. This is what
you sit through for six years. Yeah.
If that bitch own lane
knew she was get in Madrid.
Oh Damn. Crew. Hey, hey, hey.
Um, I'm just making sure
our guest is on time there.
She's going to be a little
bit late. She says, okay,
if that bitch on Lynn. No. See he was
Dupan we've been saying
fuck the points lately.
Meaning well yeah,
last night a little grilled cheese
we had in and out yesterday.
You got to do it though.
If I had a sick day.
You just want to eat and you don't feel
full ever on sick days when you have a
cold. I know. It's so weird. Like a
bottomless pit. I don't understand.
I guess because your body's burning so
much just to fight the elements that what
it is.
It's my theory.
I was thinking about how disloyal you
are and somebody sent in this clip.
This is from a show in Australia where
they test a guy's wife to see if she's f
Gtr, TD. They test the wife.
Oh yeah, we should test the guy. No,
no. See what happened. Yeah. Okay.
What's the number one element
to a successful marriage?
That's what you guys have to yell at
trust. What is trust? Trust to say, Hey,
might to detectives over there.
They're going to be working for me today.
I'm about to make a call to my wife.
It's going to scare the bejesus out of
her and let's see if she's going to trust
her. How's it going when the detectives
knock on the door? Let's see how she goes.
So this dude who obviously has
it, has, um, has set up his wife.
So here's what he's doing.
Okay.
He calls her in a panic and basically
tells his wife that detectives are about
to arrive at the house about a
date, a certain date, and he's like,
lie to them and say, I was home that day
and that's it. And then he just like,
he's like, I got and then they knock on
the doors and there's hidden cameras,
but he really fucking throws her.
Yeah.
Honey,
listen to me.
You are about to get a knock on
the door by a policeman now babe.
Listen,
do you need to do me a favor and site
team that night that I was down in
Adelaide for laneway festival?
Friday fib second baby.
Need to tell him that I was with
you. Okay. It wasn't in Adelaide.
Oh,
always. With you and the family
hearing Sydney Gary thing.
Just do it.
Gotcha.
Torturing her.
Dig Fantastic.
Uh, officers day. Look with your hospital.
I'm in the moment. Yeah. Okay. Do
you know a money model behind? No.
No.
Okay.
Oh,
she looks so nervous.
We're looking into talking to him about
the incident that happened in Adelaide.
We need to speak to him. I'm
sorry. Okay, we'll have you back.
I think he's just taking
the dog for a walk. Uh,
the incident occurred on February 2nd.
Was he a CV or an Adelaide?
She says, I can't remember. So she,
they asked her specifically that?
No, not when he was home and
Sydney and Adelaide on that day.
I can't remember what
time does he get me back?
He'll be back to that eight
o'clock tonight. OPM? Yeah.
And you can't remember any details from
that night? Friday, February the second.
I mean, she's not telling them what
he said to tell him. Right. So,
but what are, you know what she's doing?
She's, she's kind of hedging our bets.
Yeah. She's like, I don't know
what he did. I'm not going
to totally cover for him.
I'm just going to plead the fifth kind
of, this is fair. Like I'm going to be,
she's going want, well, how would you
ever be okay if someone goes, Tom,
where was Christina?
February 5th he fucking recollection.
So that's a good answer. Me and
said, I know when they say that,
then I would've been like, oh, what
date? February 2nd. Oh yeah, no, no.
She was here for sure. Yeah. We, uh,
we went out to dinner at the, um,
oh,
I forget what's the origin time play?
I would make that up because
you just called me. Well,
let me tell you what she's
doing wrong here. First of all,
when you're lying to the authorities,
you have to act surprised when they get
to the door. She's not a very good actor.
Yeah. No, I know. You need to be like,
wow, she's really truthful. Yeah.
She's a good person. Yeah.
That's why. That's why it's
on a piece of shit like us.
Right. She needs to
go, oh my goodness. La,
you guys are here. The law enforcement
here and then, I don't know.
Let me check in my calendar. February
what day? Second. Oh, um, let me see.
Yeah, no, we had a babysitter that night.
We went out to a steak
dinner on a date night.
You already,
yeah.
We'll come back and say you, man,
that's the best process moving forward.
Thank you.
Right,
man.
Sorry.
It was,
it was trust exercise to see if you're
trusting God in life where they go,
I'm the better one here.
That's what you're supposed to trust me.
Come and meet the detectives.
She's just like you. She's a liar.
She's a, she's a disloyal. Yeah.
Have gt I, she's not an Ftt Rda.
Yeah. I Dunno if FTT RTD can be,
she's not a girl that rides till
death appropriate here. Yeah. Okay.
That's for girls that ride till death
and we have it in the store by the way.
And I really hope that the only people
wearing them real little checks,
like I'm extremely loyal.
I, okay, here's the deal.
If you gave me that call and I didn't
know what you'd done at that point,
I would lie for you to the police.
Thank you.
So let's just say I'm ride or die on
ignorance and I complete ignorance later
and be like, oh, in my calendar was wrong.
I thought you meant w o February
six Oh, I'm sorry. I fucked up.
I had it in here differently.
I thought you, I thought you
meant June. Yeah. Huh. I,
I then I take it back once I found out
that you killed the Starbucks Barista.
Yeah. By the way, uh, I had, uh,
a fan of the show asked me if you've
seen forensic files. Yeah, of course.
And they're like, yeah, but they
always get caught on that show.
So the show only profiles the losers.
The losers who get caught is what you're
saying? Yes. All those fucking dummies.
FTT RTDs again, somebody with curly
hair like they're not supposed to like,
like Philippe told us too. So how do
you think you can get away with it?
How do you get away with it? Not going
to give away all my secrets on this show.
You have to burn the body with acid.
Right. It's a good way to do it. I mean,
I heard, let me know. Okay. Um,
here's an email that
bitch, okay, go ahead.
Hey, Mommy's, I'm a new
listener. Enjoy the show.
Really recently in a meeting at work,
one of the dads on my team,
I mentioned courtesy, flushing it. Oh,
he believes we don't do this enough. Now,
the courtesy flush isn't
something new to me,
but I almost never do
it since that meeting.
I've been thinking about them nonstop.
Do you do them and do they work?
I would imagine they only work in a
shit iceberg situation where the log or
sludge pile sticks out of the water.
If the shit is underwater,
how could it continue to give
off that stash? Personally,
I believe the need to courtesy flush
is rather where thoughts t money.
Uh, sorry. T I'm going to have
to disagree with you there.
I think courtesy flushes
are definitely a way to go.
You do that here? Oh yeah, you
do that for me. Oh yeah, you do.
I hear you flushing multiple times
and I think in public settings it's
definitely a thing to do. It's just
blew my mind. You realized for 14 years.
I thought that you were flushing so
frequently because there was so much brown
coming out. No. Oh, you're a courtesy.
Courtesy. Yeah, that's babe. You realize,
you know that joke you have. Yeah. We're
like, will you come out and you and I go,
do we need to go to the hospital?
Yeah, that was just because I'm like,
why is it fucking flushing so much?
It must be so much Kaka that comes out.
Well there is a lot of cockup
but my thing is that especially,
you know that first, the first release
is usually the biggest release, right?
Not In my case,
my second,
but when that comes out you have
fresh Kaka that just came out of you.
I hit flush immediately. Ah, it
sucks. All the cook it down. Yeah,
so the smell is going to be less than it
would be if it just sat there like soup
and like when you're
cooking a soup and it goes,
the smell goes through the house.
If it sits in the toilet longer,
it's going to smell own drum for sure.
No question about it. Here's smells sour.
Your puppies. All I smell sound.
No. Sometimes they smell sweet,
but that's diabetes. Have you
ever smelled me? Courtesy, flush.
Never know. Tea, smell my
browns. No, that's a lie. No,
I don't even never smelled my brown. I
haven't. We've shared a bathroom before.
I mean he's still may be some little
after remnant, but no, nothing's wrong.
I always know when you've
just gone because you leave
behind the reminder toilet
paper. It's one square and
there's like a dab of Brown on it.
It's like oh that's his last wife
and let you know that I did it. Yeah.
How come you leave that there?
I wanted you to know that I did it.
Why don't you wash it down?
I don't want you to be proud of me.
I always fleshed that for you so that
no one else sees it in the house.
Some parasailing, I'd do it for you.
You can just tell you my skills.
Look when you read this one,
marriage advice needed.
Dear Mommy's Dyrus. No wire
hangers. I know that reference.
I am so blessed to be married for 15
years to some random girl I knocked up.
It has been a great 15 years.
But I've been worried the whole time
because my wife has never given any
evidence that she shits.
No smells after she goes no
splashes on the bull note.
Nothing I'm worried cause either a,
she does shit,
in which case I'm married to some sort
of Austin Powers sex bot that does
laundry or be even after 15 years she
is still not comfortable to shit around
me. How can I help her feel comfortable
to visit Brown town when she wants?
We've been together a good while,
but even during labor with both our kids,
she didn't shit the table,
which I was looking forward to almost
as much as meeting my new kiddos.
You've both given great advice and
would love to hear your perspectives.
Please email me back
with whatever you have.
Thank you so much for your time
and entertainment and advice.
Genes update from that. Yeah, I
would say at first say to David,
just say thank you.
Yeah.
I mean you don't need her to
want to shit in front of you.
That's the last line.
So, so she's keeping,
but he's kind of worried because
there's not even evidence. Listen,
she's shitting,
but she's doing it in secret and that's
what bothers him is that she's the need
to hide. Yeah. But think
of it as it's something
she's still trying to maintain
some level of sexiness for him.
That's why I would think of
it. Ah, you know what I mean?
She's still trying to be like,
you know, we've had kids,
you've seen my pussy blown out.
My God,
we've seen each other and probably our
worst and we've been sick around each
other. But I'm just still trying to
make you not think of me as a pooper.
Yeah, that's just a nice thing.
She's just trying to be, keep it nice
guess. But I feel like that's
there. There's that level.
Like I closed the door cause I
don't want you to see me. Boop.
I don't want you to see me poop either.
But I don't,
I don't go out of my way to hide it.
I know and I feel like that's what he's
like, well why doesn't she trust me?
And that's the level she's at. She wants
it to be like that. I worry for her.
Only that she might have shame surrounding
the brown and I feel like it's not
good to have shame around Brown.
That's true. Or sex or anything. Yeah,
I worry for her levels of shame.
I mean, the only thing I
could tell you, if, if,
if you're really concerned about that,
as you could tell her, be like, hey,
you know, you know I take
big, big dumps. Sure.
I know you do too.
Yeah.
And I don't feel like you should
be a take big dumps. Yeah.
I don't think you should be ashamed of it.
You don't have to run to a
different side of the house to poop.
I don't mind you pooping.
It doesn't bother me at all.
Did she fart in front of you?
Probably not from the family.
Not just tell her you like her farts.
Tell her you want to know
what they smell like.
Yeah. Just ask her acts, act Axar acts
or that and see what happens. Okay.
You Know Jean? Yes. As you mentioned,
we've been watching so many bravo
shows. Oh my God, I, it's, but you know,
we go through phases of stuff, like we
get into scripted shows and we always,
we always go back on that
and to this episode, by the
way. No, but I, I don't know.
We'll see. But, um,
I thought we should discuss the episode
we watched with Hannah and Conrad
[inaudible]. Uh, so this is
below deck med. There's two.
There's below deck and below deck med.
Yes.
And so Hannah's the chiefs to Stuart s
and she's banging the Boson who's like 23
years old. She's 30. She's 30
yet and so years. Yeah. I said,
but, and I only just seven years. It's
like those are the quantum leap years.
Like your early twenties or so different
from your thirties. That's true.
I'm just establishing yourself. You're
still not really an adult. Yeah, I dunno.
What do you,
we've been kind of going back and forth
on the Soak Conrad in this check or
banging then dating for what,
a couple weeks?
Yeah, on a boat. You know, they're living
in this kind of isolated world, right.
Cause you're right.
Floating around,
just working together with
the personalities that
you work with and guests.
So it's kind of like study abroad.
You're like,
I think the love happens.
Yeah. And it's in this
isolated world, basically.
Everything's kind of heightened
and stuff. Yeah. So, um,
I guess he bought her a
carton of cigarettes when
they were in port and at the
end of a night of drinking or whatever,
or you're about to go out. Oh,
they're about to go out,
like getting ready, right.
Yeah. The, when he bought it, but then
they're getting ready to go out on a,
on a night out on,
all right.
So she's getting ready and it's
kind of quick and, and he's like,
they have their cabins.
Next week,
the crew does all down stairs on the
boat and he leans over and he's like, oh,
hey, don't forget you owe
me 50 bucks for a, yeah.
You want me to follow for that?
Right. He says it real casually. Like,
Hey, heads up. Do you want me
to that 50 bucks? Yeah. And,
um, she immediately was like,
okay, uh, hold on, let me
get that for it. He's like,
no, no, I'm not like right now. I'm
just saying like, it just, yeah,
I just remembered that. So I'm telling
you, she's like, no, no, no, no.
And you could tell that she's kind
of rolls her eyes. She's not into it.
And she goes into her wallet, she gets
to 50. She goes, here you go. He's like,
I didn't mean like right now. And then
you kind of think that, I don't know,
is this,
how serious is this exchange right now?
Then they get into a van and they drive
off and you can tell it's really eating
at her. So she starts to be like, oh, uh,
you got your 50 back, right? Like
you all settled now. And he's like,
I wasn't making a big deal about it.
Then she starts to do kind of juvenile
stuff cause she starts to bring it up.
Um,
like gifts that she's been
well,
and then she's like,
I had a BMW when I was 16 my grandma
gave it to me and whatever it is,
my favorite car, Hannah Fry, she
sat, they frickin this shit. I don't,
I can't remember. They all
sound Australian. Cool.
She's just really better
accents and hours.
And then they Americans go on the boat
and I, we don't want no vegetables,
no fruit. Uh, you gotta have a lot of
ranch dressing, otherwise I don't hate it.
I won't check strips ranch.
So anyways,
so she gets really bent
out of shape about this $50
Yo and then it really escalates.
Then she pulls him aside and she goes,
I don't know if I'm like
the right girl for you.
And he takes that as you have to
be someone that would spend money,
but she's saying, this is what I
interpreted it. He takes offense to it,
like extreme offense to it that,
that maybe she's looking for a guy with
a lot of money to buy her things. Right.
And then her defense of that is like,
no,
I'm just saying that if your making
sure you get your 50 back as a priority,
that's not really, it does get
complicated because it actually,
there's a lot of nuance to the
conversation and she's like, no,
I'm just saying like a 50 if you've got
to get your 50 like you're not willing
to, you know, buy me something for 50
bucks without running to get it back.
I might not be like that to me is not a
relationship. And then he keeps going,
look I am [inaudible] I am of the belief
that everything is 50 50 like down the
middle.
And of course they were like yeah this
is also where the age comes into it
because then he's saying or the reality
is that he's 23 he doesn't have a lot of
money so is it,
you almost kind of go like,
well the east should have been a
little more understanding of the other.
She should have been more cognizant of
the fact that when you're 23 years old,
$50 can make or break you.
And so like when a guy buys you
something that expensive and you're in a
position that you're a little older and
when you've been earning learning, yeah.
Like you should kind of volunteer to pay
him back and they've only been dating
for two weeks now.
This conversation is really not about
money when you think about it, right?
It's like a, it's an
exchange. It's like, er,
from a woman's perspective it's like
ill, right? I'm giving you my heart,
my poon,
my tits and all that stuff.
And you're doing like tit for tat. Like
it's kind of gross. It is kinda gross.
Not realize though that money and how
you view it and how you spend it and your
whole view on it has so much to do with
your upbringing thousand times hardwired
into you a thousand times.
I would ask for the 50 back from my
friend, but not the chicken, the chick,
that girlfriend. I know for sure.
But then see what the thing is too.
Like when you're first dating and when
I dated people and even when we were
first dating in our twenties like
we both were broke. So I was like,
I would pay for something and then you
would pay for something that's true,
but kind of by covered you on something.
I would not bring it back up. Oh, okay.
Remember when I bought that thing? You've
got to give me that back. I'd be like,
uh, cause to me that says like
that's your friend. Yeah, that's,
but that's my, I'm aware enough to know
that that's how my mind operates. Yeah.
And I also am aware enough to know that
I wouldn't want a girl to think that 50
meant that much to me.
Even if it did,
I would rather just eat that because I
wouldn't want her to think like is 50
fucking really affect you? Even if it
did, I would still be like, no, it's fine.
It's cool. Yeah. Yeah, that's,
that's true. But I mean again that's,
that's looking back on God who I was and
how I was raised and well that's how I
was trying to pay for dates.
But you were chivalrous and like,
but I think also the reason you and I
worked so well is that you always offering
to pay back in the day
when you didn't have it.
And I wasn't the kind of girl that
would take advantage of that. Very nice.
I looked out and he also did not
have expensive tastes. You were not,
it was like you've gotta be fancier.
In fact,
I our first date,
remember you, I was like,
let's go to this bar and Pasadena
that you can still smoke at. Yeah.
That was my big night
out you. That's true. Uh,
but you're about that family stuff man.
About money. Yeah. Like my parents,
I had to really unlearn a lot of poverty
thinking and a lot of scarcity thinking
and like, it's like in your
DNA, it's horrible and it's,
and it actually makes you more
anxious and it makes you reject.
It actually prevents you from earning
more money. Makes you kind of understand.
It's crazy. Yeah. Cause he talks about it.
He comes from a family where the dad had,
what was it he was,
he's found out that he didn't
see his dad for a long time.
And then when his dad did visit,
it was like his dad visited him to
verify something so that he didn't,
he had to make sure he didn't have to pay
any more child support. And then he, oh,
cool. Views with money. Yeah.
Negative. That's very negative.
And he views,
um,
anybody who wants even like you to give
them a dollar as somebody who's trying
to take something from somebody with
ulterior motives, you know? Interesting.
So in a child's mind, he
could have been like, Oh,
the reason my dad isn't
around us because of money.
I don't know what that even like people
listening right now all have different
relationships with money. Oh my
God. Some people, it's natural.
So people would naturally side
with the, with Conrad, the boy,
and some would be like, what? Just
fucking, cause she's not that.
Whether they make her out
to be materialistic, Hannah
on this episode, like, Oh,
she's materialistic. She's
just this bet shoe. Where is
he sound? Lauren. It's like,
well,
no,
she actually worked really hard to buy
those things that she enjoys wearing.
He and of course gives a shit, but
I want to throw out there, cause I,
I struggled with money for
many years. Not, I mean,
I think philosophically and
the poverty mentality and like,
I don't deserve nice things or, um,
because money's not, it's an exchange.
It's not about, anyways,
there's this great lady named
Louise Hay. She's dead now.
She just died. Louise l hey, and she
gave, there's a talk about money.
Uh, it's, you can download it on
iTunes. I recommend listening to that.
That really changed my perspective on,
on money and deserving more
in life in general. Right. Um,
you get stuck in a fucking poor mentality,
dude. That's a fucker. Did you know,
by the way,
did you know that Rosie O'donnell
played a special person in a movie?
No. Stop. I swear to you. How did I
miss this? It was just sent to us.
Jojo is beautiful and successful.
Beth has a stall or they
have nothing in common.
She's retarded
now.
They're going to be more than family.
They're going to be
a film by Angelica Houston
and was that famous actress.
She's with two Andie Mcdowell.
Rosie O'donnell,
Andie MacDowell hiding the bus
with my sister Tuesday at one watch
this whole film.
Do like a streaming Rosie.
Can we watch this full movie and
do an episode where we watch it?
We got to get ahold of riding the
bus with my sister only on BBC fall.
She's retired.
Oh,
can I watch that again?
You want to see that again?
Is Beautiful and successful.
She's retarded.
He's done.
This is unreal.
Gelica Houston did this film.
Famous lady too.
So can you imagine Rosie O'Donnell
like practicing being retarded.
Oh wait, wait. How do I run like is her
run is a little ridiculous. Yeah, it was.
It was kind of silly.
Rosie O'donnell, Andy Mcdowell, you
get into that mental place
that that's what I'm saying to,
to play one of these roles. That's what
I'm saying. Cause it's like you're,
you want to portray it
sympathetically and accurately. Yeah.
But it's also kind of funny kind of.
I like how she has a stack or cookie.
She's like,
this is what we're talking to people do.
Right. They get a whole stack. L'Oreal,
I dunno.
It's really something.
What year was this?
How did I miss this?
I was in five. No. Yeah, that's an
old, I mean, you know, relatively,
and this one kind of flew under the
radar a little bit. A little bit.
We should hide it
and this reminds me,
62 up is coming out in 2019 the up series.
We've got to go see that.
They usually play it at a small
theater here in la. If you're in,
if you're in the UK, you probably
know about the seven up series.
It started in the 60s where they follow
a group of English kids from the time
they're seven years old and every seven
years they revisit them to see the
premise of Erasmus.
You give me the the child from the age
of seven I'll show you the man to fall
percent. So fascinating to see if
you can transcend your socioeconomic,
if you really want to binge on levels.
Yeah, it's great. Binge on something cool.
Watch the seven up series. Yeah,
it's called the number seven,
you p series seven up every meeting,
every seven years.
You have revisited the same
kids every seven years.
And it is the fascinating thing
is because the premise of the,
of the whole series that goes,
show me, uh, I know, I know,
but she'll make it at seven
and I'll show you the man.
So when you see a kid until he's seven,
and I'll show you the man,
how you raised them,
how many of these kids that
you see on that first one,
and it's black and white, you know, it's,
it's whatever shifts or six days ago. Um,
and you see the kid who's like,
oh, I'm going to go to Cambridge,
I'm reading maths at Cambridge.
And that kid grows up and he goes to
Cambridge and he becomes a lawyer.
And then you see like the kid
who's a on the monkey bars, what,
why his teeth is hanging
off. And then he's, uh,
he's running around pulling his pants
up because they keep falling down.
He hasn't bought a belt. And
he's like, yeah, they really,
they show you the full run of it. It's
fascinating. It's really fascinating,
especially in the UK.
What's interesting is this idea
that you can kind of transcend your,
your socioeconomic status.
I think back,
you know the idea like if
you're born in a certain class,
are you going to be able to get out
of it and the rich get richer? Yup.
It's pretty exciting.
Pretty. Is it 62 of no,
is it 69 now at 62 right, because the
next one, don't forget to read that.
Here we go.
Stop love shaming.
Giulia to tad and crispy.
I seek your attention based
on the recent broadcasting.
Have a video made by a man.
You know what does that go away?
I don't know that the
two of you and flipper,
Sparta openly love shamed. I don't
know what that means. Giulia.
Oh, for first four hosts
our guests, Felipe Esparza.
Giulia sharing this video is essentially
revenge porn and today's climate.
Simply greeting a woman politely is
grounds for an indecency accusation and a
guilty verdict and the court
of public opinion. Granted,
the gentleman who sent the video would
be able to Texas Julia aged daughter with
the same efficiency.
If I cut off nine of his fingers,
IVL vehemently reiterate that he is
stepping into the unknown in order to
utilize his iPhone technology
and the name of love.
I formally request you cease love shaming
a man who took a huge leap in the name
of his world, Juliet. She deserves
to feel like a real woman.
She's gorgeous. She's precious.
Let's go full throttle forever.
Not Too dumb to come,
Patrick. Wow. Lesson it.
Don't fucking blame this
me too. Stuff on Julia.
Julia, don't blame the me too
movement on not being able to hit.
All of you guys know the
fucking difference. Come on.
He's something that could you imagine
waking up next to that every day.
I'll go morning talk.
Let's go full throttle.
Go full throttle.
I love you so much.
Oh my God.
The level of no one would ever love
you the way that I do so fucking weird.
Let's go full throttle.
Full throttle, full throttle.
God, that guy's really scary.
It's so scary.
He's a really terrifying man.
Yeah.
I mean before social media you would
just get creepy letters from guys.
I once had a guy in high
school notes on my windshields
experienced me. You won't even know
who your ex boyfriend is. Yeah.
Like I would follow me to Taco
Bell with my friends after school.
I had that feel terrible. What age?
This is high school. Like senior year.
He would just follow you.
He didn't go to him.
I went to an all girls high school and
this guy would somehow like break into
campus,
put a note on my car,
follow Shauna and me to talk
about and like show up there,
show up at my house. Like
really? Really Cray cray.
It's really crazy to Julia Google.
Oh Man, I will love you. Like
you've never been loved before.
That's insane to say to somebody
the day after you met them. Yeah.
That's the part where you go like,
cause there can be parts of this that
are charming, you know, could be. Yeah.
And then you go somewhere there and
you're like, no, we'll travel. Eh?
Yeah.
He's a little obsessive,
but it's been sitting in my
mind when you said to me,
you want to go back with
your ex boyfriend? Boy,
he's too old for this type of behavior
too. Of course he is. Yeah, of course.
He's old. He's like, what? 30
something at least at least.
Maybe there's forties. Let's go full
throttle and let's go full throttle.
That's cool. Full throttle. So
we get a cool guys. Uh, my man,
Gee,
I a new social media posts.
I saw it the other day and I
immediately vomited into my mouth. Um,
there couldn't be anyone weirder.
He's the coolest poster on social media.
He is the weirdest guy.
Weird. He has no cool. How does he have
like no cool to be that big of a star?
Yeah, he's zero. Cool. I don't
know if people understand too.
I think people are like, oh
yeah, he's popular amongst, um,
you know, country music.
Do you know something?
Did you know that the number
one act in the world above,
beyond say Bruno Mars?
All of them. Everyone.
Are you fucking serious? Yup. Yup. And uh,
and what he's about to do,
what he's about to embark on when he's
announcing here will be the biggest tour
of all time, man. It's our
agent's Rep. This guy. Yes,
go flow and telling you.
I love it all about it,
but it does let him be Julia Beard. It
was weird. Or Julia or this guy, right?
This guy, the full trial guys
guys. This guy of all time. Yeah.
Everybody. Garth here
in Nashville, Tennessee.
Right here in the place where we've
got inducted into the hall of fame.
Great Room right here and the
country music hall of fame. God else,
the world tour today, the stadium
tour. This is going to be fun.
I want to call it the
big ass stadium tour.
It's just stadium tour above
is all the information on it.
But what we talked about today is we're
going to introduce five cities before
Christmas to go on sale because
on insights to you, gee,
you guys asked for a longer planning date.
So can plan to be at as many of
these as you can. Here it comes,
the first two cities, St Louis
where we're kicking it off of man.
You talk about a love fest.
Last time we were there,
Phoenix specifically doing Dale Arizona,
uh,
where the cardinals play there at
State Farm, uh, stadium as well.
So those are the first two. The other
three will be announced here shortly.
And again, they'll all be on sale
before Christmas. And remember,
this is all about game day. Every show
is going to be game day or Garth Day.
However you want to look at it.
Come dressed in your full color,
support your team. Let's go have some
fun and let's get physical playing music.
I like that thought,
Huh? What the fuck is wrong with
you man? What is wrong with you?
Can I tell you what's really,
he doesn't know how to connect no beings,
which is odd that yourself
such a huge music star, right?
That's the,
see,
this is the conundrum is he's trying to
be this friendly social media guy and
he's not this guy. Let's get physical
playing music. I don't understand.
So Game Day, he means that. So
he's doing a stadium tour, right?
So all these shows will be weird.
Normally football teams. Ah,
he's like,
it's game day where your team's favorite
colors show up at the Glendale game
wearing Arizona cardinals gear.
And then because it's game day,
let's get physical playing
music. I like that, but I'm,
I'm not so taken.
Yeah,
let's go have some fun and
let's get physical playing
music. I like that thought.
Oh my God.
And then the crazy chimp smile.
Oh Man, I think I'm okay.
Yeah,
it's that he,
he must not like this process.
So much of like talking to the camera and
trying to be relatable. Yeah, it's true.
Because you know what happened?
Oh,
he probably or definitely got in late
on social media because we remember when
he was introduced to it and the
weirdest things like, hey guys, I'm on,
I'm on my space now.
Well, I guess it's official.
We're now on Facebook.
I really wasn't sure about this to start,
but then a friend of mine said something
that just made all kinds of sense.
She said think of it more as
a conversation. I like that.
I mean, that's like the weirdest
thing that anyone's ever said. I know.
So I think what happens is this is a
guy that comes from the age of like,
just do your act to do radio interviews,
maybe, you know, do that kind of thing.
So all this stuff is so foreign
to him that he's never adapted.
Like how to be natural doing it. Well,
and also, and I'll tell you an also,
he might be a monster in real
life. No, I do. I do. So he,
this is him like pretending to
be, I think he's a monster. Okay.
When somebody really smiles,
you see his smile. Yeah.
The eyes don't match the smile
when, when you really smile, look,
and it's genuine that you get wrinkles
in your eyes and the eyes kind of narrow.
Right. So his eyes are just normal,
wide open and then like this,
yeah,
that's a sociopath.
Like a chimp smile that his, his face
doesn't light up to match it. Yeah.
I think there's that.
I think that he's so forcing,
he's forcing this relate-ability and
it's not relatable. Now he's forcing,
I think he's a monster.
I think he is.
He's so afraid that people are going
to see that he might be a little shitty
because you watch somebody
like Dolly Parton. Okay.
Watch her talk to anybody and
you can tell a Dolly Parton is,
Dolly Parton has Dolly Parton no matter
what she's so she speaks from the heart.
You can tell she's warm, but
this, this guy is dark city,
darkness, darkness,
darkness, darkness. Yeah,
but he doesn't embrace the darkness.
He keeps pushing it and pushing it away.
And that's what that looks like
when you're like, hi, I'm nice.
I promise some nights it love me
and everybody likes me. Daddy.
Hey, okay, well how did
I do here? How did I do?
Hey Tom here inside your mom's house
studio where we fill every episode is
pretty cool, man. I just
want to nail down tour.
I wanted to call it the, tag it down
your throat out. You're assholes who are,
but it's just take it down. Uh, uh,
I wanted announced some days
because you guys asked me, you said,
can you let us know way ahead of times.
We can be able to go to as many
of these as we want to. Yeah,
so here's the first two men.
Oh, we're going to do the
May sonic in San Francisco,
January 4th Oh,
such a love fest there last time.
And then we just added a Oklahoma
City on Tuesday actually goes,
see commonly on Tuesday,
we're going to be Tuesday the city at
the tower theater and that's gonna be
January 22nd we're going to
have so much fun. Hey dressed.
Where are your favorite things?
And this,
this whole thing is going to be like
sports fun. It's like, hey comedy,
while we're getting physical.
I like that.
Yeah, you're super relatable and you're
connecting a normal, right? You're like,
this is a normal guy. You did
a great job. Thank [inaudible].
I was laughing as I was filming
you. Okay. Here's another,
and another really presumptuous thing
he says during the stadium tour plug,
it's like you guys wanted to know all
the dates so you can land your lives
around my fucking concert.
Not only that plan to go as many as these,
as many of these, I know you
want to come to like 10 of these
actually that's the one thing he is
actually not lying about. Oh my God.
He put a show on sale at Notre Dame
stadium where the football gamers play
fighting Irish play. And it was
like, I mean it was a minute,
two minutes. So he's like the grateful
dead cause people just follow.
And here's the thing, I was talking
to a friend about that. I was like,
the fascinating thing is like you
telling me that Beyonce or Bruno Mars or
somebody like that is a huge act or
the stones. I'm like, yeah, of course.
And I hear people talk
about them all the time.
He's the only guy who I've never heard.
I never hear anybody talk about,
and I know you go like,
well you're not, you know,
or you're not in a place where
countries big. That's true. But okay,
that's true to a degree. But
to sell the way he sells, it's,
it's in every major city to La.
I'm sure he will. I'm sure he will.
He'll probably do like the fucking
rose bowl or you know the Colosseum or
something. People in La with deff. Fuck
yeah. They love him and he's doing,
you know he's, I mean he's opening with
Saint Louis and do I mean, and then uh,
basically Phoenix. I mean those are
major cities. PHOENIX, his clothes. What,
what day is he there? Oh Shit. Here,
let's fucking look. That's fine.
Babysitters and get, go down and fly
there. Let's see. Let's see a plan.
Our 2019 or on golf shows. Tom Want
to go to as many as fucking possible.
Let's look at the attorneys. Come on,
let's route our touring with this.
I trust you all made here. Y'All made
history at Notre Dame. It says right here.
Y'All made history so he
gives you the credit you did.
Thank you for letting me be a part of
it. I am on top of the world. Love G,
g lower case g I want to go to,
oh,
there are no events.
That's good that his social media
correlates to his website. Yeah man.
Like probably be on top of this. I
want to go to Studio G. Oh my God.
Did we just hit the Jackpot? Is
that Trisha Fat Tricia. Oh my God.
Stop it. Hey, leave her alone.
Come home and you know she was bigger
back then. Now she's super fast. Garth,
uh, Notre Dame field here. Come on,
let's go see fat. Trisha, come on.
Stop saying how pink she got stuff.
It's a 21 minute.
Is that him right there?
That'd be great.
I'm just a nice guy backstage
and rehearsals to listen to that.
This isn't studio g. This is
a stage. Cool. Cool, cool.
I should do studio tours like this,
like my soundcheck come also Sirius
XM channel 55 is Gardner Facebook.
Hello Buddy. Welcome. There
is double dad wave. Yeah.
You can hear the opening
number in the back.
I'm going to get Dan to kind
of take it down a bit. Hey Dan,
I'll fucking fire you.
That's trying to be nice to Dan,
but it has to carry the
fucking thing down down.
I said turn the fuck down Dan.
You like your job.
You started touring. It's so
funny, Huh? What was so funny?
This is a big day inside
and out all day long.
So full of fucking Shit, man. Sure.
This guy is such, I just don't
buy beer. I really don't believe.
I don't believe him either. He's not
this affable. You know what Dolly Parton.
That bitch is nice.
Do you know she lets people like sleep
on our lawn and shit. Yeah. Dollywood,
she really, she's nice. Dolly
Parton is nice for real. No,
it's going to air. The Notre Dame show
is going to air on CBS on December 2nd.
Okay. That will to CBS with this guy
says this show was different. Uh,
Garth is one of the very few artists from
the planet worthy of staging the first
ever concert at the venerable venue.
Um,
oh and he played through horrible, uh,
what's it called? Weather conditions.
Okay. He's this great performer. Oh,
it talks about relate-ability of
Garth to the heartland. Sorry,
our guest is here. Oh really? Okay.
Why don't we take a quick break. Okay.
All right. And we're back. Uh, the break,
you never know about it just happened.
And we are joined by somebody who we've
been trying to get on this show for a
while and she's finally
here. Please. Uh, hold Europe
for David Letterman. Hi, it's Andy. David.
Any better man? I'm so bummed because she
usually wears her Adidas three stripes.
I was really excited to see
you and that's why I wore it.
I've worn it the same night as
well cause you look like you could be
my tribe in eastern bloc or vibe to you.
Well I feel like I started a posting my
pictures and thing and people were like
what about Chris?
Like they were like,
they were trying to start a
beef between us. No such thing.
I love and respect you too much. There's
no way. You're like one of the girls,
the comedy store I always liked
cause you come, you come with jokes.
You know what I'm saying? Like I
like I always respect a female comic.
Any comic that comes and tries to like
take a swing, do, don't just push the owl.
It's a wild thing to not do comedy
while you're on stage. Right.
It's just so like what? Why would
you put the audience through this?
What are you doing and all the like,
it's so lecturer in shooting now two,
it's like what you're not,
you're going to not only not do jokes,
which is what they paid for,
but then also like condemned their law,
their lifestyles. Right. What are
you doing? Cause you can make fun.
Like it's fun to make fun of people you
don't agree with because that's the best.
It's like when you write a joke that's
good enough that you're both laughing at
them. That's like the ultimate,
I don't know why people,
yeah,
we're in this place now to where it's
actually the reason that there is people
lecturing all of that is
because comedy is so popular,
so it's actually great that we're
in a business that is so popular.
It's so big that people who
suck at it can still do it.
Yeah.
People accept that.
Like they're one of the people they it
to like the boom I'm or the night. Yeah.
It's fantastic. If you're
actually good, not in a boom.
Only the really good people get to do it.
It does feel good.
And by keep complaining
ladies keep coming. Yeah,
I'm just going to keep doing the spots.
I love it.
And that's why I love Annie Letterman
because you're fucking ride or die.
She's the real deal.
She grinds that whole bullshit to that.
I've heard they're like,
there's no women at the store.
I've been at the store with a bunch
of women. They never mentioned
me and those arguments,
because I don't fit the narrative because
I'm not like a famous draw a really,
you know,
like some people will come out to see
me but I'm not going to like fill the
seats. Like I'm not the one like
making the main room a or whatever.
So they don't bring me
up because you know,
like I just showed that you can like,
like work hard and do the job
and not like what like, you know,
when you guys are counting lineups,
like when I was at your stage in comedy,
I was like, uh, doing like I
was like on stage, you know,
it's not like I had all these people.
I remember when I started
doing Mike's and uh,
New York and these girls would get
mad at me. It wasn't just girls,
but it was like,
you know,
this certain like class of comedians
that I like I guess started with,
they would get so mad.
Like I had one girl who like blocked me
on all these social media things and I
was like, wait, what's happening? I
see you every day. And she was like,
I'm mad because you, you always leave
the mix before I go on, I'm like, bitch,
you aren't on my radar. I've never
met you. I'm not friends with you.
Like oh this is my job. Like
I wasn't getting paid at it
but I was like, you know,
I quit drinking to do this. I moved
to new, like I, I sacrificed a lot.
I didn't have friends. Like I was
like wanting to do it. So I was like,
I had a day job working as a
waitress and I would immediately,
I had my hustle down where I had like
friends that would sign me up from right
there. I would sign them up
and I was doing like five
Mike's a night. So I'm like,
what's a, what's up bitches? I'm like
crying blood at the end of the week.
What are you doing? Wow, you don't
five mics. And then I had a, yeah,
it was a Mike Lawrence when I
first started doing open mics.
I've been doing comedy 10, almost 10 now,
so I still feel very young in it. But,
um, I had moved, I had lived in
Santa Fe and I was drinking a bunch.
I quit drinking,
moved to New York or move to Santa Fe.
I lived in Santa Fe for seven years.
I went to college there to the College
of Santa Fe, which went out of business.
My College fucking Trump feud.
They went out of business. Um,
I got an email from my, I
had moved to New York. Um,
I had all these incompletes and I just
figured like I would graduate college at
some point before I died and
left Santa Fe, moved to New York,
had just quit drinking and
started doing open mikes.
And I get a message on my Facebook from
one of my old art professors and she's
like, um, I just,
the is going out of business and we've
got a record of all the people that have
been completed to do a foreign completes,
but you have two weeks to finish
them if you want to graduate. Yeah.
And this was a bitch that would like,
I would skip her class and she
would call me and I'm like,
get away from me bitch. Like, what
do you my mom click? I'm like,
I'm in college now. I don't have
to go to class. I'm like, no clue.
So what did you end up doing?
Um,
I ended up getting an
Adderall prescription and
charging on my credit card,
a bunch of flights and shit.
I had to fly to Santa Fe twice in two
weeks because I had a statistics class
that's so hard and if I like statistics,
but it's like memorizing
all these numbers and shit.
And it had been years since
I had gotten my incomplete,
where I just like didn't do a midterm or
something, like something where I just,
I used to send it to my teachers. I'm
like, I thought it was called my terms.
I do them when I want.
Like I just was,
I was such a small school and I just use
my gift of Gab to get through things.
Um, but the, the guy that
wouldn't, the guy that was my
statistics teacher was, uh,
it was, the school was founded
by the Christian brothers,
so he was like this Christian brother
who brother Brian who was like,
he looked like the salary on Veggie Tales.
Like he just had like the craziest,
like shaped head and shit.
But he would wear like this cloak with
like the rabbit teeth things and they
were just so weird and it was like,
they looked like ghosts from another time,
but he was very strict and like what,
just give me like,
my other teachers are like,
just write something and we'll
just, you know, give you a grade.
He made me fucking, he gave
me, first of all, he gave me
a d. I flew with her twice,
but I had to learn, relearn
statistics of all. Let's try my lease.
I paid a girl in beer to do my
statistics labs and call it.
That's how much I couldn't do it.
I was so stupid with math and it's like,
yeah you can't,
well you have to pay attention so much
and you have to completely get the
concept of it to yeah. I'm not
interested. He said about 10 years ago.
So this is like 2008 yeah,
2008 you start doing Mike's in New York.
It's something you always wanted to do.
I wanted to do it. I moved to, I was
drinking so much and I crashed in my,
I had a motor scooter that I crashed in
Santa Fe. So how much were you drinking?
A lot. I was like Jaeger for
breakfast. You're hardcore. Yeah,
well I was like dealing with a
lot of like self hate and shit,
so I would just sort
of like squash it down.
So you had to start early in the
morning for that. I drank all the time.
I drank all day and I had a motor
scooter and I was also a waitress and a
bartender.
So it's like that sort of culture where
everyone's drinking in Santa Fe is a
very small town of like a lot of people
are retired. And then she was like this,
this younger, there were like two
colleges but there were small. Um,
but you know, it was just like a weird,
like, what are you going to do? You know,
always nice. Yeah, it's
beautiful. It's beautiful. Um,
so do you stopped drinking there
before you go to New York? I go hard.
And Santa Fe and Santa Fe go hard.
And then in New York I'm going hard,
but it's like nobody else's, like
it's, I'm just on a different,
I'm on like a desert level of drunk.
Like I'm like,
I was like an Indian casinos with
Indians and you know what I mean?
Or am drinking, um, am drinking all
day dreams. Tell me, tell me that.
Like when you wake up, is it like
you'd go to your cabinet? Well,
it depends on like it was, it
would depend. No, not cabinet.
It would be like I would wake up late
and just probably go to bars. But I had,
I remember I had a boyfriend once in
college who was so gay. It was like,
I mean he's married to a
woman now. I don't share it
as a kid. I think he's like,
I want to have to fuck her stinky
Plessy. She's already got a kid. Um, but
she's so grouse or tuna
anyway. But um, she, he, um,
we would drink a lot to
think he was drinking. Like,
cause he was like going try to like, but
it was always like, he was always like,
let's have this dude, fuck us.
I'm like, all right. I'm like,
why are you looking at him? But it's so
weird. I thought it was just get so drunk.
Everything was like,
so like partyish or whatever.
And I remember we would invite
threesomes. Is that you're saying? Yeah,
well there was way we were always part.
There was always a party where it was
never like how he was a guy into this.
Never had, there was never a girl.
Straight guys aren't into that.
Another dude and the party.
I used to always an college and make my
boyfriend's make out with other boys and
be like, to assert my dominance over
their own sexuality. Whoa. Yeah.
And they would always accept and they
always broke up with me as soon as
I have a deep voice and a mustache.
So I think I like attract,
I'm like the guys like
last dude like, but he but,
but that guy we used to,
we called the Jack Daniels Oj. So
in the morning we'd be like, Yo,
pass the Oj damn.
Like then you're going hard.
You're not drinking wine or beer and
you're like, Yeager, Jack Daniels.
I wanted to get fucking blackout.
Take a break from this bitch.
Have you been in therapy or have you gone
to any kind of program or counseling?
I went to therapy a couple
times and then I was like,
they keep making me mad at my parents.
It's so annoying.
And now I'm like in a rage and my parents
like I should probably go to therapy.
Yeah. I was like, why do they keep
bringing my parents up? It's like, I,
I've dealt with that. Um, but I went to,
I did go to Aa for a year or not for your,
sorry for three months,
but it seems like I'm a chip. And then
I was like, oh no bitches. I'm fine.
It seems like you have a good, I mean,
listen, I follow you on Instagram.
I see that you visit your family,
you seem to have a good
relationship with them now.
They did some terrible things
though. Like I'm like, wow, I'm like,
you motherfucker, you still like them.
I love them. It's Stockholm Syndrome.
I don't know. I love
them. I'm just like, well,
I just started playing
hard to get with them.
Like I realized I was holding a
boom box up to my mom's window,
like playing on your eyes. I'm like,
why am I trying to fuck my parents?
It literally feels like I'm like
strangling a puppy with them and like,
I love you so much. Why don't you
love me back. And so I'm like,
I'm not calling them. And I'm like talking
to them not that often. I'm like, Yo,
you guys remember when we used to talk
every day that was literally just me
annoying you. So whatever.
We'll see. Oh I'm,
yeah, I'm, I'm not yeah, I love them.
I forgive them. But um, so they,
I want them to feel a little guilt that
they don't feel that what you're saying,
if you feel like they don't love
you, they don't show you. No,
I know they lack a paralegal. You know,
they love me. I totally know they love me.
I think that maybe,
um,
my ability to love is a little
bit stronger than theirs and,
but it's probably be a product
of the neglect as a child.
It's just my mom like,
didn't I keep thinking about it?
Cause I was talking to my boyfriend
about it and they didn't teach me to like
read and stuff. Like they didn't, I
didn't, I just am learning about history.
Like they sent me to a juvenile delinquent
school and I had Kinda wasn't like
everyone got kicked out of their schools.
I didn't, they just like were like,
there's an art program. Like they
just put me in a school with like,
like young criminals, criminals.
I was like, no. And I was like,
smoking a cigarette here and there.
I was like, I wasn't like a good kid,
but they were literally
not paying attention to me
that that was like an Annie
door instead of a job to get it over,
just like send me out. And they're like,
she'll come back,
which it's like when I'm hungry,
but it's like I was like a cute
little kid. Like I was kind of like a,
a pretty little girl.
And so they just,
they didn't realize like what did they
know they were sending you to a juvenile
delinquent school? Yeah. I
don't know what they do that
well.
Are they immigrant? And by the way, are
not my mom was adopted. It's like, wow.
Well why would they
send you to that school?
I mean, okay. So they
didn't teach me anything.
I was never taught manners
or how to act or anything.
And then I'll kind of get in trouble
just like for just like existing the way
you would like, I pretty much was
like the jungle book. Sure. And um,
I'm like jungle, I'm just wanting
topless just in a loin cloth.
Everyone's mad at me. Um, but they uh,
Brown skinned at that time too. Oh boy.
But they, they sent me to, so they would
just like send me this, I don't know.
I was like hanging out
with adults all the time.
I may just like always had like grown
up friends who wanted to hang out with
like a seven year old. Do you know
how fucking weird that is? Yes.
I just was getting dead left and right.
I mean they were literally just like,
do you want, they're like, oh, do you
think our daughter's beautiful? However,
it just was like very,
my mom was mad.
I'm a twin and she don't
only want to have two kids.
And I think she like kind of like was
like overwhelmed and I was terrified and
she didn't. My mom had a pituitary,
I had no idea when she was little,
which was like a, a growth in her
arra tumor on her pituitary gland.
So she didn't like it or period
till she was 19 or anything.
So she has like a really
weird relationship with
femininity and she was adopted
so she's like pissed her birth mom. Yeah,
these are all things I'm just making up,
but I think I'm ready. I think
I'm correct. Like she's never,
I mean she will confirm,
I guess she's always like,
you always call me out on
stuff. I'm like, well dude,
one of my friends never call me
as a kid was super artsy,
just like [inaudible]
creative kid and his parents.
One day we were in the same school
and then he started going to school.
He was like, my buddy, you know? Yeah.
And so I was like, where is he in there?
Like a sound to another school.
And they arranged for me to visit him
one day in that school and I visited him
and it was a,
an extra,
like a school for extreme
developmentally disabled.
I walked into his class and it was, what
was it called? Landmark. But I was like,
the fuck are you doing here? And he was
like, yeah, this is where I go to school.
Like I'm retarded. I mean,
yeah. Can I say that?
I can talk as I can say retargeting
and bags. I don't want to out you,
but they said you have to say retarded
or are we delete the episode?
They banned from the stuff.
So yeah, it was um, it was at I,
I mean there were kids like bouncing off
the walls. There was super violent kids,
people, this was like my school and I was
like, why are you, and then years later,
you know, he's a totally just
regular guy, sweet, sweet guy.
And I go, what? Like what was that
all about? And they're like, yeah,
my parents just thought my like
artistic inclinations weird.
So they just sent me to this
school and it was completely,
I'm sure traumatizing actually to him
to be there to see your surroundings.
And they're like, this is where you
belong. You belong amongst these kids.
Which he did not. Well, it is weird when
you, when you're put in a group like that,
you're like, wait, is this
what you think I am? Is this,
what year was that? Did that really play
or was that just in my head? I'm like,
I hear that all the time and that
exact boy every time I'm about to talk.
Um, but no, it really is
like a weird thing because,
you know,
they just wouldn't brother.
And we were held back in kindergarten
because of my brother had learning
disabilities. And then, um, in
second grade when I couldn't read,
um, they were like, well,
my mom would always tell me,
well then we found out about your
learning disabilities in second grade,
which is like never
needed to tell me that.
I could have just told me the
part where it was Max. But, um,
so then I'm thinking back on
it. I'm looking at, I'm like,
I don't think I had reading problems.
They told me I had a tracking problem.
My mom likes sent me to this like whole
institute and so all this stuff where
it's like, mom, you never
sat down and told me to read.
Why are you acting like I was
supposed to just know how to read?
Like she literally never,
I said that I got she, um,
school home to me. She's like,
I thought she just sent me to school
to do all the home things and yeah,
she was like, they'll do
it, but I'm like, you know,
all the parents are like also
sitting down with their kids.
It's not like they're just sending them
and like the teachers have like all
these other students.
So then I would stay after with my
regular teacher and she would give me,
and then I learned to read really easily.
It just sounds like, you know, I mean,
I think my mom wanted to
have a fucking nar, Nar, Nar,
Nar, Nar. What do you mean? He was just
another word for retired, those evil.
I also was a special ed teacher, so I
should be better about this. But now,
you know,
I'm learning about this in therapy because
I fucking hate my parents too. And um,
it doesn't go away. When you have
your own, it actually gets amplified.
What happens is when you start to
raise your own children, you go like,
what the fuck?
Wait a minute.
And you start to go back
into your own things and you,
you know, you have to free,
I forgive, obviously I'm not like
actively angry anymore anymore,
but you start to realize like they're
just incapable of seeing your needs,
which is so devastating cause you're like,
why did nobody see that?
Why didn't nobody realize that like
little Annie needed help reading or it's
just so wild. It's like, why? It's like my
mom in front of my boyfriend, I was like,
mom, I don't remember you like teaching
in or did you teach me to read?
And she starts laughing. She's like, of
course not. Like she thinks it's so funny.
She's a fuck up. I'm like, you
could just try to be better.
What about your other eye? Did
they learn to read? Um, Ma, no.
Ever. They, they gave us both. They
give us all like disabled, like things,
you know? Oh God. It's just like, wow,
how did they get my number? It's just,
I get calls all day and it's all like
some robot bitch or horse or political,
remember your taxes. And I'm like
trying to forget them. Stop doing that.
Are you kidding me? I do this
at in the morning. Not now.
Yeah, but it's infuriating
when your parents don't see
you or don't care to know
just how the,
when I'm like,
I'm telling you the exact truth and I'm
giving you even the words you could say
back. Right. And you
can't do it. It's like,
but I think there's so many like secrets
that people grow and I think that
generation too,
like we're much more like we talked
to like telling everyone all our shit,
but it's like, um, you know,
like there's so many secrets and there's
so many things that you have to tell
yourself and lighters of about to
not like let the dominoes fall.
So I do understand that, but
it's like, I'm just like,
you guys are in the evening of life.
Do you not want to like settle the beef?
Like this is it, right? Like I'm here
being like, come on, let's do this.
And it's just, my dad said he would go to
therapy with me and then I was like, oh,
he would. Yeah, my dad would be my dad's.
My Dad's cool about it. It's just like,
I don't know what I realized the
things that I need from them,
I just need to give to
myself and there's just no,
and I just need to get your a narcissist,
she sounds like.
Yeah, it's hard. It's really hard to
have a parent that's like, they can't,
they don't,
do you want to hear about my
last show in Philly? Yeah. Okay.
So my parents do the landmark forum,
um,
which I know that's amazing that they
even did that. No, they didn't do it once.
They've been doing it for 12 years.
You know what I do,
you know when you do a thing and it's
supposed to teach you how to like go into
the rest of your life and we'll
explain to people what landmark is.
Self Development. Um,
it's called [inaudible].
It's like, it depends on how you use it.
It's, but it's a self development thing.
It's a derivative from s and
you go on to like a seminar,
you go into a seminar and it's
so you'd pay like, I don't know,
it's like 800 bucks or something.
Which little pricey. Um,
you go into a seminar and there's
like one leader, there's no,
all the walls are white, you know, all
the chairs are uniform. You sit there,
it's like really, you know, they force
you to pay attention and it's all about,
it's kind of like, it's
a lot of different, um,
yeah,
theories of, uh, psychology
put in one, but it's, you know,
essentially like you're getting to the
point of like where your life is empty
and meaningless so you can fill it in.
You're creating these stories,
but there's all of these like specific
words they use, which I, you know,
I did it when I was 19. My parents
want me to do, and I did it and it was,
you know,
it's that feeling that a weird feeling
you get in at the end of it where you're
kind of surrendering
and it feels very cold.
It feels just very like a religion
almost. People always. Yeah.
I mean,
I didn't go through it,
but you hear a lot of times
people describe or liking
it to some version of like
Scientology. Right? So it's just very,
yeah, when I saw the Scientology thing,
I was like, Ooh, the shades
Atlanta, it's like therapy.
But in front of other people.
From what I understand, like you,
you give speeches to hundreds of other
people and you share all these very
personal things with groups,
right? So it's not like,
personally I never said white people
didn't take all that money and just go see
a therapy
one for a decade. Also, they
pull, they pull you. I know.
It's like a cowardly, the,
I don't know. Like for me, I do
anything but that like, I'm like,
I guess I believe in psychics.
Like I guess we get my Tarot cards read.
There's something like, so confronting
about therapy I think for people,
for me at least. And of course,
yeah, it's just a lie. And I'm like,
I'm paying you this much fucking
money. But, um, all right. So, uh,
with the thing, the problem that I had
with landmark was at the end of it,
they then go, you should
reconnect with all these people.
And I've had a lot of people do me dirty
and I always accepted responsibility.
My parents included, where it
was so hard for me to, like,
I didn't want to blame anyone else.
It just seemed easier to blame myself and
to just believe I was like born rotten
and I was just like this
bad seed or whatever.
Then to admit that literally every
fucking grown up in my life, let me down,
did not do their job.
And that to me was like a scarier
world and just being like,
I'm a piece of shit living in this course.
Right?
So then I'm in landmark and
then at the end they want,
it's all about like reconnecting
with anyone you have
any sort of like ill will with
or anything. And it's not,
that's probably not the message of the
landmark. They probably don't say anyone.
But to me it's like I'm nice and I
want people to like me and, and uh,
with, you know, with my, at that stage,
especially with my parents and stuff.
So it was like, I'm like looking
for this like approval all the time.
So I wanted to connect with everyone.
Now I'm at the age where I want to
disconnect with so many people. I'm like,
get the f like, yeah Yo, if I
haven't talked to in four years,
don't you dare ask me for free tickets.
Right.
Get the fuck like I don't know you are
but whatever. Maybe not four years.
But it's just like, you know, I was
like collecting people all the time.
So then when landmarks sort of at the
end of the weekend when they're like
reconnect with people,
I'm reconnecting with people that really
fucked me over like not fucked me over
in a little way,
but like that are not,
are dangerous people for me to be around
and then I'm having to call them and
tell them what I did wrong.
Boy, like I'm what's called,
I had to take a teacher to, to court for
sexually assaulting me and he was like,
God,
I broke this whole ring of his.
Like it was like I was sexually assaulted
by a teacher for real and I actually
went to court and no one believed me.
And you don't need people to believe you.
You need the judge to believe you anyway.
You don't need your friend.
It's like a popularity thing to be like,
I don't fucking need that.
Like that's like a, you
took him to court. I go to,
but um, he got three years probation,
so I'm like, I couldn't put, yeah,
he pled guilty high school or now
he's, um, I think he wasn't allowed,
I can't remember what the thing the deal
was, but middle school, high school,
I was in high school,
I was 15 or 16,
and then I'm no help from anyone.
I mean it was like really it was,
it was and your parents, my parents
did, but it's their fault. It happened.
So it's like, uh, you know,
looking back I'm like, oh,
of course they wanted to like settle
and stuff because my parents just, um,
I was just not, I was given no rules.
I was given no discipline at all.
So I was always in these crazy,
dangerous situations.
And I also wasn't taught that I
was good, you know, like, so I was,
my mom is very competitive
with me and she would do that.
She was so antifeminist
femininity because of, I believe,
because she didn't have her period and
shit until she was older that it was,
you know, she, her way to like relate to
dudes was to like, Bro, you know, like,
which I do too, but
it's like sh, you know,
she was always like the only woman on the,
she would play like men's racquetball
rather than, you know, I'm just like,
she always had to be like the
only girl. So, um, so then,
um, she, it just was very
like, uh, yeah. I don't,
I don't know, but just so they had earlier
before that happened when I was 15 or,
I'm sorry, this is what I
was saying. My mom would, um,
she never would let people say
I was pretty or anything. Like,
it was always be like, she's
smart, but it was like, I didn't,
I literally got the message that I wasn't
pretty, which like I'm not, I don't,
I think that it's gross for girls
to run around and being like,
I'm hot shit or whatever. But I
think there was a level of awareness.
I was a level of attractive that that was,
it was dangerous to send me out.
Like it was like, um, like
I was just, I was a girl,
she was treating me like a boy in
a way, you know, I was just not,
the boys don't get molested all the
time, but it was like, I just, um,
I just had no clue what I looked
like until like this year.
So I was always like confused. I'm
like, I'm flashing my tits. Why?
He's never mad at me. I look like a
boy. Like what? You know, like, oh,
I don't look like a boy.
Um,
and so there was just like this
kind of like nagging of my,
of my looks all the time to the point
where I wasn't sure what I looked like.
Right, right. Cause I can
be, it's bad on the others.
I can understand why she
probably overcorrected because
on the one hand to tell
the little girl she didn't want
to be lying. Yeah. All the time.
Then you turn them into a dumb role with
no identity. Right. But to go the, Oh,
the overcorrection is to not acknowledge
that you are an attractive little girl
and that people might want to prey upon
you. It was just like very, you know,
we were brought up Quaker, my mom, which
we weren't what we were brought up.
Quaker just not our mentioned now. And
that's how many layers are there. Jesus.
A lot of layers. When does the
book come out? This fucking crazy.
Wait, what happened last time
you were a, did a show in Philly,
you were going to say? Oh yeah. Okay. So
I'm in Philly and, um, my mom, uh,
she was landmark.
So all of her landmark for shooting bites
all over laminates and all today it's
at, um, punchline. So she
invites all of her, you know,
which it's like, all right,
that's cute that you're, you know,
cause I'm looking at it like she's proud
of me or whatever, but that's how it is.
Okay. That's not what it is. You're
an extension of her. Right. I'm, I'm,
uh, I'm someone who's getting
a platform that she can take.
I don't even wouldn't even say
an extension of her. Um, I,
I wouldn't even say I would
love to be cleaned like that.
I wouldn't want you to be like,
that sounds so awesome. So she, um,
all of our friends come and,
um,
and it's Christmas and my mom owns an
Ebay dropoff storm and I might eat my
mom's Ebay drop of sore.
She gets a bunch of weird shit and so,
and she thinks it's funny to give us these
gifts and none of us think it's funny.
It's always annoying. It's always like
some, it's smells like someone's basement.
It's like, oh, can you get this away from
the children? Like my nieces and nephews,
just like, everyone's like, please stop
bringing this trash into our house. But,
so that's like her big bet is that
she brings us like weird shit from,
so I'm onstage, I'm just starting, I'm,
I get really nervous in Philly because
I had all this stuff happened in high
school, so I, I really get nervous.
People are going to, I don't,
I don't like anyone from like my friends.
Like I'm like,
I don't want anyone from my
high school to show I'm scared.
I have a lot of predators
there. So I'm like, um,
I got real nervous and may feel
he shows and um, I was trying to,
like I was working on, I wanted
to get a tapes. He had a special,
and I was like telling my mom that
day I was like, I really need to,
I'm just nervous because I
really want to make sure I,
I have a good order for my jokes and I
just want to make sure I stay on track.
I have so much anxiety. Okay. So the week,
I'll tell you about the year before
when I did Thanksgiving there.
All right after this. So she, so for
some dumb reason I forgot my mom's,
my mom and I think me telling her this
will let her know to really not interrupt
and not be difficult.
She drives me into the,
I go with her and to the, to the club.
Okay. So I'm with her the whole time.
So I don't see her bringing anything in
or anything because I'm just not paying
attention. I'm just like a
little bit nervous trying
to stay on track, get there.
She's trying to it. I'm like,
I don't want to be your friend.
Like I don't have time for this. I
have to like, you know, kept pumped.
So I get on stage and I'm,
I'm, I'm a little nervous.
I have a like a rougher
start than usual and uh,
and maybe five minutes in when I'm just
getting my, starting to get my bearings,
she throws a present onstage.
Okay.
She snuck a fucking president.
She snuck a fucking present in through
it and threw it onto the stage. She goes,
Hey, I got you a present and throws like
while I'm in the middle of the joke.
So then, okay, so her friends are
there, but they're not, it's, it's like,
I don't think I was sold out,
but I was like a few seats
shy being sold out this month.
I don't know how those
motherfuckers do that.
We're all of a sudden I'm not getting a
bonus. I'm like, oh, that was, I'm like,
how did,
how did my people just not,
there couldn't have been like five more
people. But anyway, it was very close.
It was like two 55 yet to 51.
It was just like,
but it was like they were
telling the truth. I'm like,
it was like when they see it, I
was like, oh, I'm so almost a draw.
But then so okay,
so then,
but so she makes up like there's
maybe like 12 of her friends,
so she's not making up that much of the
audience, but it's enough where I'm like,
Ma, you know, like, so she, so she throws
the present on stage and now I'm like,
I gotta I just barely gotten the
audience on my side. So now I'm,
um, I have to take a present,
open it, like in retrospect,
I should've thrown at her.
He's like totally took,
taken her down as if she was a regular
person and not my mom embarrassed her in
front of her friends and possibly had her
kicked out, but I was still being like,
I don't wanna hurt my mom's feelings.
Right.
I don't wanna embarrass her in front
of her friends. So I'm trying to like,
make it work in both ways.
So now I have to,
I have to get away from the
microphone to open this present.
My hands aren't on the mic.
My hands are now doing another thing.
I have to look down at a thing.
I have no control over the
audience at this point. Right now.
People are looking at her.
I have to now,
now and then what it is is it's a
fucking like an arm, not like a,
not like a sexist but like uh,
like an arm that nurses would use to
try like their ivs on or whatever.
So she throws his arms like,
so now I have to explain
who my fucking mom is,
what her job is, why should we give
me this present all this stuff.
And it was just like,
so I was so mad and I had a really bad
set cause I was so like of course and
like it was like I got like bad
review. Like I never got bad. Like,
I mean we all get bad reviews here and
there, but like I never get in Philly.
I usually get like really good reviews
and it was like, I got like bad,
like I got like people were writing
about it like she saw like all this,
I'm like, mom, you fucking bitch. Like
yeah, that's my money. Like that's my job.
Like, and I remember like talking and
she was like, what? I'm just like,
well how did you go? Sorry, can't you just
like get over it? Like I didn't mean to.
And it's like, let's play this out.
Let's say that had killed what?
Where would the audience be looking
at you bitch, not at me like that.
It wouldn't like you just completely took,
so then you didn't like the gift. Yeah,
she was like, come on, I got you
an arm thing. Maybe I did lie.
I do actually have
of Jada Pinkett Smith about this.
I've been sitting here and just thinking
about forgiveness and it's been a deep
journey for me because I've had to look
into the shadows of my own heart and
understand how I've heard other people
and forgive myself for any wrong
accident. My, for what you're
doing to me now you're, yes,
you're not my people.
I had to clear myself with my own shame,
my own guilt, and have compassion
for myself and forgiveness.
What is selfish apology,
right?
Why does everyone think everyone gives
a fucking shit? It's so unbelievable.
What is this new thing where
it's like everyone's like,
vulnerability is strength.
And now my, like, I'm bipolar
in her like, Yo, I wouldn't,
maybe not like,
well,
and there's a time and a forum where you
could all say your shit, but it's like,
I'm just saying,
everyone's like not on social media
is my thing where it's like the, the,
like the where it's like we're at
this place where it's now like,
like naked chicks showing their cellulite
and they're like, look, I'm Bree,
or brave or whatever. I'm like, getting
attention for your body is not bravery.
Like that's not,
they were like,
now I can also do this thing that
was also kind of gross appropriate.
My favorite are chicks that were, or
their ugly mud masks. They're like,
look how ugly I am right now.
It's just,
yeah, it's silly. Uh, but by the way, we
have to watch red table talk on Facebook.
Oh my God.
I've never been more excited for anything
as if the gift that Jadah provides
isn't big enough. She is coming
out with a new show with will. Yes.
We're going to explain everything.
Yes. On Facebook. People crying and
breaking down. Do not bring me today.
I've broken you enough.
All right, so hold on, let's clear
something swinger. Just historical room.
Jadah Jayda deep down inside
I was insecure little boy.
That one jaded is say I was great.
You know why I never got divorced?
It's cheaper to keep me,
it's so interesting to me that they're
willing to put like they are doing the
social thing. They're movie stars.
You know? It's like, but what is,
what is driving the necessity like that
guys says he wants to do any movie.
It's just like greenlight. We'll make
it any anytime. What do you think it is?
She wants to humiliate him.
You think so this whole thing,
am I broken you enough? No, no, no.
She wants to. Why would he agree to it?
To distill the gay rumors. Yeah,
they're going to just still those,
they're going to just steal
the open marriage rumors.
They're going to discipline. She also,
part of her wants the acknowledgment,
the recognition for being jade
Pinkett kid into it though.
It's like they bring the kids in
that willow, she's good on it.
Cause I had been watching red table talk
on Facebook and she's probably the most,
my most favorite part of it all because
her face is funny. And she's like, Damn.
Like she makes these cute
little faces. She's a gift.
She's very, she's very, yeah,
she's a total again,
but she's very likable.
The kids or the kids sweet now Jadah you,
she gets very vulnerable.
She talks about why she's been wearing
her head wraps lately. I'm fascinated.
I was hair loss. She's had
hair loss. That's fun. Yeah.
And then she talks about sex with her
grandma and her daughter and went up to
the that vulnerability. I do
appreciate it. Amaze. It's on.
It's on Facebook watch and
we have to start watching it.
Talking about sponsored by them.
Um,
do you guys know that it's a
full time job to be a good dad?
He got so much more stuff than I had.
It's the lyrics to
that song. I was like, it's a
full time job to be a good dad.
That's right.
I forgot that horse more of an option.
I be like part time two of us.
Right?
I think you were cheaper when I met
you when I started most definitely in
personality or moneywise.
Um,
now are you a frugal person
or how do you approach no,
I just make money and then I spend it
all and then I'm broke and then I freak
out. And that's your pattern. Well,
these are people who are
the extreme of cheap.
I think they'll, you'll appreciate
them if this is what I think it is.
It is about them. And I was
like, that's so crazy that sheep.
I was like, well smiths afraid
he's going to run out. No Way.
Is this a TLC show? Yes. I already know.
You already know. I fucking love this. Um,
but go ahead. Just some of it's
just going to fuck this shit.
I live for this. So this is my bathtub.
Look at it's brand new and shiny.
I don't even have to clean it. There's no
mildew. All my crowd, which is amazing.
I has never cleaned it
because I've never used it.
I have a gym membership and
that's where I take my shower.
I like to work out and kind of a gym rat.
I'm there every day anyway.
Well first of all, it's not. I mean,
what do those traps? She's like,
this is on the rat. My urine.
In an effort to save money,
I started peeing in a jar.
Just uh, maybe to save energy.
I like to be in your bed, but don't go
into the bathroom. Wait, why did she say,
she's reminding me she's going to save
on the water bill water bill. Yeah,
just what she does. We're going to get to
that. Somebody's got to planet fitness.
A $10 a month. Here you go. Big
Time, money savings, quite pungent.
And the longer it sits,
the stronger it an apple juice.
One line that you can put your
urine into your compost pile.
And I thought, Wow, I can pee
in a jar. Build my compost.
Oh God, no. He used to shoot
from Philly, right. That acts,
haste and that one when it's on
one over easy exit over there.
It's a gross accident.
How much can you save pissing into,
we're about to find out why would
you do $30 a month to $20 a month?
So there's $10 right there. So I pee
in a bottle, but don't get me wrong, I,
you know, I pooped like everybody
else and I put that in the toilet.
What did in the toilet flush,
there's a middle man. The process,
I put the with the toilet,
I poop over here and then I put it in the,
and she sells over handmade jewelry,
but she also has some Nice Ted's.
It's like, come on girl, get a Webcam.
She has a, she says she flushed
twice a day with the browns. Yeah.
So she's got healthy movements.
So she saved $10 a month doing
way bigger psycho like that.
This lady, this lady makes that.
Is this how you guys stay in love?
You just look at people that are
way worse than you? Of course. Yes.
I don't do laundry.
You have to pay quite a bit in quarters,
so whenever I have dirty clothes,
I tried to watch them while I'm showering.
I'm using a free sample of detergent.
I got detergent and reach my clothes,
put them in the shower.
I love this. I love it.
I get it.
Whenever did this in college,
make it on camera again.
If you're willing to get naked on camera,
you can make some money. Exactly. She's,
she's halfway there.
She says the last time that I did laundry,
it was three years ago,
three years ago,
and they start ringing out in
these clothes. It gets better.
She's a yes.
Just want to do all that expensive
laundry and don't use the dryer.
I only does it ride
around waste money,
but it's a shrink's clothes and
their wears clothes out faster. Yeah.
You can keep your clothes looking new
order for longer if you don't dry them.
No,
the Jewish Asians,
well, normally I wouldn't want to maybe
a load of laundry every other week.
It's cost like $3 to wash and dry clothes.
Say maybe $6 a month.
$6 she's not destitute. I mean,
look at her bathroom. It's nice.
I mean that's six bucks in your pocket.
That's actually her whole apartment.
You didn't know that she lived in
the bathroom. This is like an Indian.
She pays us $50 a month
to live in that battle.
Now I will admit that in college I may
have hand washed underwear a few times.
Yeah, that's not that crazy. Come
on. You guys wash your underwear.
You guys were underwear. How old
are you? He doesn't wear underwear.
It freaks me out.
How do you have your deck rubbing against
denim jeans and so it doesn't burn.
I know. Told us. He's just
like, he's got stuff to do, man.
He's doesn't that time to put
fucking underwear all the time.
How's he gotten rid of that
eyelash? I can't. No, it's so,
it's truly upsetting. I know. It's like,
it may as well be like an ass hair.
Like there's just, it's like so decided
for a decade now since we've wait,
you mean it's never,
he's never gotten rid of it now
he's had it since we've known her.
And imagine how many times that
comes into your just I, yeah.
How does he get out when you, when you
see one kind of like an eyebrow here.
Oh Shit. Took a point. I don't
know how many deals with that
toilet paper. I just use water
and soap to clean myself off.
After going to the bathroom,
I'd take his water bottle that I have
and like rinse myself off if I just
urinated, it's, I'm done with that.
And then I dry myself off with one of
the paper towels I have if I took a dump.
And then I also ran a salt
wipe myself down with soap.
Do you see how little that soapland chalk
and rinse off the soap fights?
I don't believe in spending money on
something that you're just going to throw
away such as toilet paper or paper towel.
Yeah, I think the day bitch cause
I do. Yeah. She's a little proud.
A little proud of it. This is
mental illness. Proud of this.
You think she has a boyfriend?
No. Or do you think she's proud?
Do you think she's like, do
you think she's like, like,
look how, look how awesome I've,
I've figured this out. Yes.
She's telling you I've got a system here
it is. If I took a dumb yes, the best,
breaking it down, I just felt
like she wouldn't say dumb. Yeah.
I don't think that that like pretty clean.
Her bow pose.
A pretty clean clean for sure. She's a
soap on on her. After you had the baby,
they tell you to squirt your vagina in
the same way it did look like a baby
thing. Yeah. If you're done yet,
there's a square bottle and you have to
wrench or virgin off that way we just,
Tom not know about that. Did you know
that? Did I hit the squirt bottle?
Are you able to stay separate from
the stuff? No, I knew about that.
He's sought a square bottle side by
the potatoes or the little Filipino.
Listen if I was a kid,
I'm going to make my dude fucking
know everything and be like,
you have to watch it fucking heat.
I have to stand next to me cause
I use that to like know how much.
Like you have to listen to me complain
while I'm doing it. Yeah, he did.
Don't worry is how I would even saw
it come out. Both babies. Right.
You catch it and my badge blast, but
I was right there. I was right there.
I mean I could've caught it.
Yeah,
I could have caught it and I did the
little umbilical cut and so sweet. Yeah,
it's fun. You want to see the
video? Yeah. Yeah. I can't
wait. Is it on Youtube? Yeah.
All you do is you tag your kids. There's
all these like birth videos on youtube.
I'm like,
why don't you,
those kids are going to like
the youtube generation batch.
Like they're going to fuck him. Yeah.
Find them. I want to see your mom's purse.
You want to see your own head
coming out of Pittsburgh? Yes.
So it's too intimate to share. That's
crazy. It's a wild thing to share.
I don't like the oversharing and I don't
like so proud of it. It's like, yeah,
but it's like it's a unique experience
to yourself. Right? Like in your family,
you and your husband. I don't like the
sharing of a, everything the kid does too.
Once it's, you know, it's weird. It's
just not, the kid can't consent to that.
Especially if you have like any
type of fan base. It's funny. Yeah.
You don't want them talking to
you too much about your know. Um,
you have a boyfriend,
but in case you ever are single again,
Kinda always have them. Here's
some good advice. Somebody. Yeah.
Hey everybody and welcome to today's
episode of the wanderlust thinker,
part one and dating for
Gen x and those over 40.
So as it generation mail,
where do we go to meet single women?
That is a big,
big question.
It's, it's, I always think it's
interesting that he's at a playground
and right. And when you're a
self appointed authority on this,
who is not hitting it out of the park.
Yeah. I mean like when you're not,
it's like, it's like are you asking you a
question? Are you telling him? Yeah. Yeah.
Facial hair. A town. Yeah. Slim pickings.
Pretty much the interesting you
brought up slim most everybody goes
well, very good. I'll do one set up
and then maybe we can talk about it.
He's got a good point and I'll
tell you what Annie, you're right.
The fatness is only accentuated by
this cut his prison pussy and it also,
it does kind of look like
as an extended asshole.
So what is it like a gaping
asshole? Yeah. Yeah. Not a good look
are crazy beat up women or women that
are addicted to pills or ranking or other
were just to have some
men issues all together.
Maybe he's scarred a little bit from
some past experiences because there was a
lot of restrained emotion behind
it. Yeah. And it's always the, well,
let's say the portly or unsightly men
that tend to have really high standards
for the, excuse me, excuse me,
don't regurgitate people from high school.
There's a reason they're in your passion.
Remember you're a generation x, are you?
But at a high school longer than you
were in high school and it's been a long,
long time.
Most of us graduated in the eighties and
nineties most of them go back and try
to grab that girl that you had
a crush on me. Do not. I repeat,
not do online dating.
I don't care how many friends you have.
Where are we supposed to go?
Know somebody that knows somebody
that met their wife on online dating.
It is a waste of,
trust me on this guys,
if you ever want to feel like
a leper in your basement,
spend some time on online dating and
also if you're from a small town like me,
nobody picks up a woman that
you're interested in a local bar.
There's probably 20 other guys are
all trying to get with her secretly.
I remember we tried to shark your shit.
Okay. This guy's a real expert, Huh?
I mean, so far he's also not, he's a,
he's like that critic that tells you
everything that's wrong. Yeah. You know,
here's everything that's bad
about everything, but no solution.
They took all of the options
out. Yeah. Some will. How,
how's it going to go back to high school?
Get out of this small town.
Don't go online. Don't go here. I guess
the park is the leading option right now.
Come to this park. You got to meet a
nice young man on fortnight. I mean, uh,
I work out four or five times
a week. Oh, okay. And I'm,
I'm not the best work out of my
basement. You know, make an effort,
make it better for his looks are fleeting.
Now that doesn't mean go out
with like a 400 pound woman.
Yeah.
You can't be the one that
mentioned the way a honey bold.
It's the expectations,
right? You guys got it.
You can not put demands on
bitches like this. Also don't,
the high school thing makes no sense
because you can easily reconnect with
someone. Like don't maybe think it's
going to be the same person. Yeah,
no question. I know he's watching this
guy has been, he's been burned with fire.
He's very,
I feel like Emirates and I mean never
stand for being in the friend zone.
The girl says to you, I look at you as
a brother, or I look at you as a friend.
I look, he goes, my fat brother
don't stand for arrogant women.
If she's stuck up,
she isn't worth it.
A lot of women get big heads because they
get a lot of guys flirt with them and
I'll tell you what, they're not worth your
time. They're not that great. Remember,
they got to bring something
to the table. Okay? Remember,
you're the highly caloric to find somebody
that you want to spend your life with.
What's going on?
I know is I areas not good here.
Oh, this is sad. This poor guy.
You don't need the drama.
You don't need to build anybody.
I mean, his advice is
depressing. It's just,
it's really sad and it's all knows.
It's like,
here's a million things you shouldn't
do. Goodbye. Also, here's the thing,
I've dated some pretty big guys. Yeah,
I don't have any problem with that,
but you can't be like no fat,
no fat checks. What the fuck?
The fattest guy I know has a
no fat check policy. Seriously.
I mean like he's dead broke at
a divorce. It's really, I mean,
like I know a guy who
seriously like three 50,
he's very unsightly and, and it's
fine. Right. But then he, his law,
his list of demands for
women is kind of like this.
They just have to buy a bitch from
overseas. That's what that exist for.
Like the brides and
the Asian ladies, right? Yeah,
the commands of the world.
Yeah. This is a Fucking,
I got to pee. You guys
work it out. Oh Geez. Yeah.
Your apple get your apple juice
bottle. Oh my God. Anyway, so,
uh, I don't, I ask you, how old
are you? You're on 30. 40. Wow.
He looks so young.
So you grew up in the dating
era of like Tinder and shit?
No, I never, I, I really like
my job. I don't, I don't like,
so I never really was like trying to,
um,
like have boyfriends that
much. I was just like, oh,
they're going to like keep
me from my job or whatever.
So I never was like actively trying to
date. It would just like happened to me.
Like, I honestly feel like
they all tricked me and Oh
man, apology. Except now,
now I'm happy.
But
all right, so you've been with the
same dude for how long now? A year. Oh,
that's super new. Yeah. But we
were friends for like seven years.
That's the way to go.
I think that's the way to go.
Yeah. He's my best friend. It's so fun.
It's like great. That's awesome. I never,
I always thought you like,
they came separately,
like love and intimacy and
then friendship, you know?
I was like, oh you fuck.
And then,
yeah,
so I would be like hanging out with him
and then we'd be having like the best
time ever. Just like literally
like writing jokes, laughing,
just like till our stomachs
hurt. And then I'd be like, oh,
I gotta go back in this guy that parked
my car the other day who I really like
looking at this man, this fucking guy,
you know? I go like Fox, I'm like roller.
I'm like this guy.
Rollerblades
so how did it,
so then did he like bring that up to you?
Yeah, he did. Yeah, he did. He was like,
you've kind of already been my
girlfriend for a while and it was like,
he like Jedi mind trick males
like I guess, but I was like,
I was not thrilled about
it. At first. I was like,
how dare he had promised he
would never. Thank you. Um,
women helping women. He, um,
yeah, he had promised to a number hit on
me, so awesome. Cool. Then when he did,
I was pissed.
But yes.
Is he your first serious boyfriend
or how have you done boy,
um, I mean I'd had long term
boyfriends, but they weren't serious.
I was always like, this is terrible.
How do I get out of this? I dated a guy,
I dated a guy for three years
who I just, I mean, it was,
it was rough
for three years,
like on and off.
No, lived with him. Oh, I
was homeless when I met him.
I was living in my car and,
uh, this was the rollerblader and
then, um, he's like a nice guy.
He's a nice guy from jersey, like
reminded me of home who's younger than me.
Um, and he was like, you know, he wasn't
gonna make me like stay in my car. I mean,
I wasn't living in my car car,
but I'm,
and I was like sort of sleep like I
would crash and I'd never hear here and
there. And so, uh, he was like,
stay with me. And then I was like,
already I was into him in the beginning
and then so I was like living with him,
but then it was just like three years
went by and I was like, I'm going to die.
Jesus.
I'm going to fucking die.
Wait, so you never got to do online
dating and stuff. I went on to, Ooh,
I want on, oh, this idea of a good story.
I want them to, I went on to things,
but I thought it was just
too bad. Like I was like, oh,
I went through a breakup or something.
I want to like fuck someone once or so
I went on, I did Riaa Joe
Riaz. It's like the celebrity,
the celebrity one, they
exclusive like, sounds cool.
It's worse. It's like, oh, hey,
do you want to go on a date that, um,
we'll also potentially hurt your career?
Well, awesome. Well, it's
just like we, it's like,
just want to go on a date with a
producer, like only somebody in, yeah.
So it's like, it's just, it's Ryan,
my friend Karen Says Ryan stands
for rich asshole young asshole.
But it's like very, it's like exclusive
and it's just like, it's a weird,
I don't know, to me it's, it's just weird.
It's like you're like, Hey, Matthew Perry,
uh, or whatever. Do you know what I mean?
It's like you're just like, it's like a,
we, it's like weird,
you know, like, oh, um,
but I never like cared about that shit.
I never was like, I want to date a celeb.
Like I never super weird.
I know you're married to one,
but you guys are selecting. No, I was
thinking cause uh, cause uh, Steve Simone,
then there was like, we need a
celebrity. It was like being,
so Steve just came at you with such, like,
we've known him a long time, right? Yeah,
of course. So it's like he's had to
transition the way he talks, like,
do you know what I mean?
Not that he hasn't always been that way,
but like now he's like, he's
like, um, you're, and it's
like it was cause you are,
but it was, it was just like the
way he said it was like very,
it was just very cute. He's
so sweet. He's opening for me.
November 24th in man, Diego,
California. At the House of Blues.
We plan with the school thing. We planned
this whole blog. Yeah. That was seamless.
I know, right? He's so funny. Can I
tell you what I love about Steve Smith?
A positive energy. The guy always, he's,
he's not talking like dark shit
like we do. Like he's like,
remember when you had pizza? It's
like ice cream, but he's genuine.
He really loves that stuff and he
brings the whole room up. Like, Gosh,
she's such a such a diamond. I really
love that. And he's a good human.
He does charity work for
true TV. Never. Not, never,
not farting guy on Twitter.
His handle is never not funny.
He was a fan of our show.
He's Brad
had to get him in the other pilot.
One more psycho cheap person.
Oh I love this. I could do this
all day. It's so fun to watch.
Fucking misers are my favorite.
I'm cutting toilet paper
squares for background. Sure.
Wash and use instead of paper products.
We have a little band
underneath the basket,
the little toilet wipes or we picked
him so we can wash them later.
It's time to wash and just for a minute
I ever have to touch them with my hand
paper to anything.
For me as a middle class family
that makes a good income,
I should and we'd have to go into
debt to buy toilet paper and you
don't, that's the other
thing. Here's the thing,
they always think they're saving but the
energy and time spent cutting up strips
of cloth and then nuts
like the dollar store,
say 99 cents store way.
That time I want to do is I spend
19 hours a week cutting and washing.
And did you guys do like organic
diapers and stuff? Did you try to do?
My friend is pregnant and she's like,
and I'm like, I'm just the high.
I'm like, she's already like talking about
Oregon. I'm like, wait, organic diapers.
I'm like, wait, or like
cloth type cloth diapers? No.
Why don't you just not do this to
yourself? Like why are you already like,
I have heard such nightmare
stories about cloth diapers.
I just feel like you're going to,
it's going to blow out once
and you're not going to gross.
Just ruin the environment for three years.
None of our cloth wipes that we've been
using them for more than five years of
the marketing nuance saves
us $20 a month over a year.
Then that is 245
Ooh,
she's on the sped 10 hours
a day. Cutting strips. No,
I spend that on Amazon everyday.
Like on like toothpicks. I'm like,
what should I get today?
I had one person say she couldn't
continue her washing machine.
I just had to laugh because of you know,
anything about and bacteria.
There's no eight can survive those harsh
conditions and so what your own asshole
issue at all.
She's mocking her friend who said,
do you want to wash your shit paper in
the Washer? She's like, that's silly.
Bitch doesn't know what she's
talking about. She's like,
I'm wearing one of my shit.
Rags as a,
the kid had a blow out the baby
and his pajamas or whenever,
and nanny goes to put it in our washing
machine. I go, don't you fucking do that?
I got this from old navy for four 99
I can afford another form if fuck you
don't,
don't put it in my washing machine here.
Has the kid has better intuition
about mom's nonsense here.
First came up with like the kids,
a little skeptical and once I got used
to it and to me it's something solid on
your hand.
The paper stuff,
the shit that's on your hand,
that solid chest. He had good.
He goes, this is kind of dirty, right?
It's clean.
It's
okay, so she's trying to clean. He's
like, this is staying with Kaka Mommy,
and she was like, no, no,
no. This is clean. Oh my God,
you use that? Mommy said it's okay. This
is my favorite one. For some reason.
I really liked that lady. Oh,
you know what's another one?
I really don't understand the extreme
couponers they spend 10 15 hours a day
cutting the coupon,
putting the coupon into folder binders,
and then taking it to the store. It's
like for that, that's a part time jobs.
Ridiculous.
Yeah.
Just figure out a job that you can earn
more money instead of trying to find a
way to not spend money. You know what
I mean? It's sort of course. Yes.
You know they don't have a job.
You're doing a job like the guy,
like there's this guy that is outside the
rite aid near my house and he's always
like, he's always asking for it. He's a,
he's like a like a like kind of
handsome black dude, you know?
He's like maybe 25 or something.
Who knows? It could be 65
your number now. But um,
he's like holding a cup out. I didn't go
or just, or just not cup. He goes, hey,
it's like hard times. Can
you give him? I'm like,
do you want me to give you an application?
Because me handing your money
is exactly the same job.
Like no offense to people that work
at write it, but it was like, dude,
I think you can probably get a
job here probably. Yeah. Yeah.
Like I could get you like what do you
want if you're standing out there all that
time and it's hard. It's
weird. And everyone, the woman
that worked there was like,
yeah, what the fuck dude. I yeah.
Also it's hard for me to make
money course back in the day.
You mentioned you are always forcing
your boyfriends to kiss boys. Yes. Boys.
Did you ever get into other kinky
like in a kink stuff or no? Um,
I like to be jerked off in
front of just getting a diver.
You kink of the air?
Um,
oh.
I think I was just like kind
of down for whatever. Okay.
Or were you down for this?
Imagine if the easiest
way to delight your wife.
She just drove all across room
relationships. Wouldn't tell me
I'm feeling that tails getting fucked.
I feel physically ill with the pup play.
Yeah.
It makes me very uncomfortable inside.
I liked the original kiwi pup play,
the deceitful one. They're
like, this is not sexual,
just a bunch of men
wearing leather and math.
And then we found his other channels
where he was like inserting mass down
there. Yeah. Is that a butt plug
tail? This one probably wasn't as,
so when it's all dudes, it definitely is
what it's dudes. They're like leather.
Like get on the table that the vet needs
to inspect you and then yeah, there's,
I went to a leather vest and silver
lake, um, maybe 10 years ago. Yeah.
Leather daddies. And they were
the, they have assless chaps. Yeah.
And um, which I've never seen
asphalt chops to be honest,
but with butt plugs that look like towels.
And then there was a guy that was,
had a booth that people could come up to
and they would zip you up in a body bag
and just your balls about it and he would
whip your balls and people were like,
there was a line around the fucking
bottom line. Can I tell you what that is?
That was San Francisco in the late night
and that was, so that was the weekend.
That was a good time back in that city.
You were there for like the real,
the height of Gay Shit,
man.
There were dudes just butt fucking in
the streets back then. It was awesome.
I think if this women's movement knew
a little bit more about like dom shit,
like they'd be happier. Like
yeah, you can like whip.
There's dude you can find that will let
you whip their balls will actually ask
you to, maybe they don't
want to do it. I can do that.
I would do that for money if
I weren't married. It was,
I guess I love no, if you,
if I loved it. No, I think
here's what I would do.
Anyone tolerates that level of pain.
It's gotta be,
there's gotta be such a more inward
pain they're trying to hide. Oh,
that's an interesting, I mean, I'm
like, that's interesting. Like shit,
trying to mask the inner pain inside.
That's how much worse the pain is on that.
It's interesting that your balls whipped,
but I mean,
I'm saying there's a physical pain. It
changes obviously from person to person,
but for a lot of guys,
wear anything aggressive there
will physically make you collapse,
like nauseous. Right? Absolutely.
I know, and when people say to me,
don't you feel resentful that you have
to carry the baby for nine months and
then pushed the baby out and then
breastfeed the baby? And I go, no,
because then two and a half years when
that little boy is running around,
he's going to kick daddy right in the
nuts and it's called payback because I
loud every time was actually trained
them to do it. We have lessons.
He's homeschooled and
kicking down the balls. Oh,
you've won all these ribbons at dog shows,
but they rarely ask.
If I'm the oh boy.
Quite a few that's rude to go into it
to try to win as a human. It's not fair.
It's like Oscar Pistorius with a fake
legs. A little bit of an advantage.
Don't name is Tony and I'm a human pup.
I'm Tony's husband and trainer.
Oh,
that's a twist.
That's quite a twist and they have
real dogs are not neuter involved.
Even though it was balls with my entire
life. A lot of kids like to play.
Pretend they like to pretend to be, but
I really fuck them. They enjoy doing it.
I just never grew out of
that pet play through Tony.
Once we start dating or is it common?
Who's Tony? Tony's on the left.
She is glad to do it. I say
when the student is ready,
the master appears. Oh boy.
These two are a match made in heaven.
Doggy heaven. All dogs go to heaven.
They're dogs are super cute. I feel
bad for them now. What's Your Pronoun?
They're like, they go to Costco to get
peanut butter. I bought Tony. Definitely.
He she's observes aspects of to mind
that relate to BDSM or kink or leather?
No, it involves gear that is
restrictive or restraining. For example,
leashes, harnesses, myths on your
hands. You know what I don't like?
I don't like how put together they are.
I like having my pup play psychos
to really be out on the edge.
I don't like, I don't like an articulate
explanation actually don't like that.
It's like half shaved head.
Like I want you to look proper.
Like I want this to be more of a twist.
I want you to be like,
like Harvard educated. Yeah. I
like to be caught off guard more.
Or just, I like when they're like the
fakeness of like, this is just fun.
Kiwis and out with the guys and
then there's just like fucking,
do you want to like the
Obamas to be doing that?
To try to have like a broader audience?
Like they're pretending like they were
like, we want the Christians like as too,
they just want, they don't want
to come off as weird. Right. It's
legitimizing it. Right.
Oh, we have these harnesses
slowly is similar to the
responsibility with a regular dog.
I have to groom the dogs and my wife's
hair, that's pretty, I have regular dog.
I'm just different. Okay. Okay. He's like,
we have bio dogs and I do train
them barking, but you know,
if you want to make a big stink
that's you're an adult human,
you could do you want it?
Okay.
So that there was pretty,
cause she,
she took offense to the fact that he was
like, you know, we have like real dog.
She's like, I am a funny, can I hear that
again please? Yeah, that was pretty great.
That was perfect.
Great.
Hi.
Responsibility is similar to the
responsibility with a regular dog.
The first expert.
I'm a regular dog. Just different. Okay.
She is rough
bio dog.
Have you been a horse trainer?
A harsh chair since 2009 we can I just
say, can you pause it for a second? Sure.
Because before we even get into
this bitch, um, she's a cha. Okay.
So what annoys me about that is like if
you want to be like a weird dog badge,
be a dog badge, but don't, don't be
precious about how your dog bitch.
Yeah, you are weird. That is weird. Okay.
And tout that you're weird and you found
a fucking husband who's like totally
down. I fucking do your gratitude
list in the morning, bitch. All right.
You can write it with a little pause and
don't, but don't like correct. I'm like,
he's offended you like,
it's not like he has to accommodate
you more than he already has. He has.
You're eating out of a fucking
dog ball batch, like a, come on.
He said regular dog and you're supposed
to say buy a real dogs. Don't do that.
Real dogs don't go like far. Far fewer
like disrespecting my pronouns. No,
she's out of
Annie. Do some role play. Be like
you're my bio dog. Tell Tom you're,
I mean you're my regular dog.
You're just a regular dog. It's bio.
Wow,
I love this and that's the
day I love this safe space.
Do you remember that guy? Please explore
please. We need to hear this Mumbo jumbo.
This is this and critter
club is to provide a safe
space for people to explore.
We engage in pet play.
People don't realize that safe spaces
inside yourself that is the same.
It's really like you have to just
accept herself and not worry about other
people because you have no control
over how their people treat you.
You'll literally have no,
all you can do is set up boundaries and
people either cross number don't and
then you have them in your
life or you don't like,
it's what is happening right
now. Yeah, it's all victim
culture. It's a, yeah, it's,
I have to change the external world.
You have no, it's like people have not,
I've used that real shit happens.
So it's like,
think it goes up around your
house broken into or whatever.
I feel like being like fucking raped
or having like your house broken into.
It's like these things that
happen where you're like,
you realize like your
walls are not their fault.
It's like this barrier is like not
real. Right? So you just have to be,
you have to be your walls.
Like you have to try your best to like
protect yourself and you can't just like,
it's just, it's just, it makes
me crazy, crazy, real wisdom.
It's fucking the, I just can't
believe this shit. It's like,
I don't give a fuck about your dog shit,
but I'm allowed to make fun of you.
I'm sorry. Yeah, of course.
We're going to be weird.
If you're going to put it out
there like you're saying. Yeah,
and you can make fun of me, mother fucker.
I'm not saying you came in front of me.
It's like who wasn't made fun of. It's
so important to me. Made Fun of like,
especially as comics, like I
mean, come on, we all got dragged,
dragged and it's like you learn how
to get through it worse. But no,
you have to go to a safe
space and do your pony play.
But I'm going through something. It's
like, yeah, so it was Roseanne Bitch.
Like what the fuck? Like and you can't
everyone so hypocritical. Oh yeah.
If you want. Okay, fine. Then we have to
be like, feel bad for everyone. Everybody.
Everybody's a front.
If they voted for Trump,
don't feel bad for them.
Quintessential head play gear,
his tail and hood. Everything else
is extra. Okay, so let's do tail. Oh,
that's not extra. Okay. The
tells that extra for me.
The reason that I like to be a dog,
his dog is man's best friend.
Dogs experience the world
through a lens of pure joy.
I ever seen someone that cynical
as am more maybe dolphins,
but I feel like that pet
play would be much harder.
It's all I trained off late pony
and critter club is kind of Ooh,
head play dress up like that style.
There's no sex involved.
I don't think sexually sexual.
I do think that to an extent is is
for Roddick because it is intimate.
I'm sorry it's not sexual.
He's wearing fucking pleather
from head to toe of course.
And it's all harnessed and
belts all snug on drafts. No,
it's totally something. I put a fake
tail in my asshole, but it's not sexual.
It's like you guys pretending that you
weren't going to fucking put that bottle
right up. Tom's that what bothers me too.
Along what you were saying. Uh, the safe
space and then the need to, you know,
everybody's different and we have to
honor what they're doing. It's like,
no you don't. You can talk shit
about like, this is ridiculous.
It's remember when you could just
call crazy shit crazy. Yeah. Now it's,
you're considered crazy shaming.
Craziest like the most fun thing to
point and laugh at because what keeps you
feeling like when you're
making fun of someone,
you're fucking including the thing.
It's like I'm trying to get on a level
where I can relate to you because what
you're doing is fucking crazy.
If I wasn't making fun of you,
I would be judging you.
Right. Do you understand?
If I was just silently sitting
there and going like this,
I would be repressing every thought I
had about how fucking nuts it is. Yeah.
Or I can try to make the rim left. Bust
your balls and then map it out. Yeah.
I consider myself, I thought you died. I
got excited. That being said, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. I didn't
hear it. What is she saying? Yeah.
I consider myself out. I'm
very open. That being said,
I do compartmentalize my pet play because
not everyone wants or needs to see
that families. First thing she said, yeah,
I think they have a general
idea that I'm to deposit,
but you don't talk about it.
They know.
She talked about it like
she was considering going
to thanksgiving dressed up
like that, so I like, yeah,
I mean I guess this is one of our big
points on these people all the time.
A lot of times the people insist on
everybody knowing what makes them come and
it's like you don't have to
tell everybody and she actually,
I'll give her credit,
keeps it to herself that like this is her.
I mean keeps she's off, but at least
she's not. She's like saying like,
I don't tell dad and does it a joggy
mentoring guys. I'm a comedian.
It is a documentary,
which that I applaud like just keep it
to yourself if you're going to be weird,
just do it behind closed doors.
Why does everybody have to celebrate
everything you're fucking doing?
How annoying is that as someone with a
narcissistic mother, how annoying is that?
If your owner is like taking the toy,
you're like, Yo, can I get the toy?
You went to pet smart and came back
with nothing for me. Just for yourself.
This is a nasty or stealing your dogs.
Then I will say,
if anybody is meant to be a dog,
it's that broad. Right? Yeah.
She fucking looks like a human dog.
She does.
She cut her hair like a dog
and she's very ruthless. Um,
she's a doll. She's
fantastic. I almost want to,
we got to watch those again because I
feel like I didn't fully get the essence,
like I need to soak it in. You haven't
gotten, I need to take a second pass.
I was like, I've got to soak, if you know
what I mean. I didn't get wet enough.
Right. I'm really, and I haven't
come yet. We have to watch it again.
But there are some videos on this show
that you take one pass and you're like,
that was weird. And then I think about
them for a week and then I'm like,
we got this. We got to do guys ever. Are
you ever like, we've got to try that? No,
just mock them endlessly.
Any where can people see you coming up?
Um, oh, I just have my
date up and I forgot
and he's a great comic. You need to go see
her live. She's Ah, often at the store,
one of the few ladies that's allowed to
perform that very funny lady. It's hard.
I had to, you know, complained.
I complained a lot online and
then they finally passed me. Yeah.
That's the way to do it. I did
not go into the line and, no, no,
you just have to complain
about stuff. Right. You have
to be a victim. It's crazy.
Um, let me look up the
state. Go see comedienne. Uh,
and can I tell you my finish my
Brian's story? Yeah. Oh yeah.
So I go on a date with, and you know,
like everyone's a liar and everything,
but I thought they lie about like height
and stuff. This guy, um, cropped out,
he had a like a lobster claw hand
cause like a deformed hand and like,
I don't care.
I was a special ed teacher.
I'm cool. But like it was um,
it was just so surprising
and we never talked about it.
And then he took me into a lobster
restaurant he did with his lobster. Yeah.
That's nice that we didn't talk about it.
No,
it was totally random and I was like,
cause I was like,
I don't want to do a bit about it.
I talked about it on stage but it's like,
but I, I didn't want to, I was like, I'm
not going to talk about this on stage.
Do they tend to labs?
The restaurant.
But then once he took him to
the labs restaurant, I was
like done deal. Sorry Bro.
But it was wild.
I'm like just hope like,
cause I would always make sure he
could tell it in a big boobs and stuff.
Like I never wanted to have
the moment of like discipline.
I just never like if I'm not your type,
you're not mine.
So it's like I'm not going to like go
on a date with someone and then show up
and you're like look different
than your picture. Yeah. Wait,
but this is a famous person with a
lobster, you know, he was like, I don't,
he like had a picture of one direction.
I'm trying to think of famous people with
lobster claw. No, no, no, no, he's not.
He's just, he was a nice
guy. It was just like,
and I wouldn't have it just once I saw
that, I was like, yeah, that's weird man.
Just show your thing. We are, what's
your website? Where can people find?
You can find me. My website is
not updated. I'm lily. I'm not,
I'm bad at that stuff.
But um, I will update it.
It's anti letterman.com but also a,
I will post most of my dates on Instagram.
There you go. And that's just at,
and I run, but so I'm doing and
Letterman is led. It's l e d e r.
M. A. N. So I'm gonna be, uh,
in Poughkeepsie. Wait, no,
I'm going to be in Saratoga springs
at the comedy works. No, New York,
November 23rd and 24th with Kurt Metzger.
Okay. It's fantastic. Yeah. Hilarious.
Kurt Metzger and Annie together.
I've worked 23rd and 24th. Um,
thank you very much for coming today.
Thanks for having me. This was really fun.
Yeah. Thanks for showing me
the world of dog play. Yeah,
we felt like you had the note.
You're a great guest.
Thanks a here's gaping dad with,
she's our worded on the way out. Um,
joy is Christ the rest of your week,
guys. We'll see you next. [inaudible]
thank you, Brandon. Get over it, but yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're targeting,
you got to get off.
You got to get off the bus.
You don't,
you don't,
you don't.
You don't mind.
Do you ever see your mom,
your mom? Yeah, my mom. Did
you ever date your mom? Yeah, my mom.
Yeah.
Hey.